Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass, die 2. Männer-Bundesliga. Auch sie geht in eine Winterpause und wir wollen noch mal draufklicken. Alle Teams können wir nicht besprechen, aber dann doch das oben und das unten und ein bisschen was von der Mitte. Jetzt gleich hier im Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt zu diesem Rasenfunk Kurzpass mit dem Thema 2. Männer Bundesliga. Und ich habe es schon angekündigt. Es wurde auch vielfach gefordert. Wir haben hier eine ganz besondere Runde, die ich begrüßen darf. Ihr kennt sie schon aus der letzten Erstligasaison unter anderem. Ich begrüße hier zum einen Eva-Lotte Bohle vom 2. Bundesliga-Pod, die Ed Eva unterstrich Bohle. Hallo Eva. Guten Morgen. Und ebenfalls hier ist Michael Fischer von den Nürnberger Nachrichten vom 4. Flachpass auf Twitter der Ed Flachpass unterstrich. Nochmal danke dafür, dass du deinen Händel irgendwann geändert hast. Seitdem kriege ich es fehlerfrei hin. Hallo Michael, schön, dass du hier bist.
Ja, ich habe mir lange überlegt, wie wir über diese Hinserie sprechen und ich habe mich dafür entschieden, zumindest wenn es zwei Minuten mehr kostet, aber ich denke, die haben wir, nochmal zurückzublicken, einfach sogar ins Aufstiegsjahr. Wenn sich jetzt manche fragen, warum, aber der Name Stefan Leitl ist natürlich ein sehr, sehr wichtiger. Der ist ja gegangen nach dem Abstieg aus der Bundesliga, in die zweite Bundesliga nach der vergangenen Saison, aber das war eigentlich schon relativ absehbar. Wenn man so nochmal mit Menschen spricht, wenn man auch nochmal einige Aussagen, Revue passieren lässt, dann wird sich einiges erinnern, als Fürth aufgestiegen ist, nach dem Spiel gegen Düsseldorf im Mai 2021. Da hat Stefan Leitler im Interview sehr lange gehadert und hat gesagt, er müsste das alles erst mal verdauen. Das sei sehr anstrengend gewesen, auch für ihn, für die Familie. Das war offenbar aber jetzt nicht der einzige Grund, was man auch danach von Spielern gehört hat. Stefan Leitler hat damals schon gehadert, in die Bundesliga zu gehen, mit dem Wissen, dass man vier Spieler verliert. Wenn man jetzt die Bundesliga verfolgt, David Raum und Anton Stach, auch Paul Jäckle bei Union. Man hat da ja wirklich Spieler verloren, die prägend waren in diesem Aufstiegsjahr. Und er hat damals schon Angst gehabt, in der Bundesliga zu spielen mit einer Mannschaft, die schlechter ist als die in der 2. Bundesliga. Und das hat sich dann eben fortgesetzt. Und dieser Trend, das führt natürlich die besten Spieler nicht halten kann. Auch aufgrund der finanziellen Mittel und weil man sich auf die Fahnen schreibt, Talente auszubilden und Spieler im besten Fall zu verkaufen. Das gelang nicht in allen Fällen. Aber zumindest hat man für Stach sehr viel Geld bekommen und dann jetzt auch für Leverling. Aber das war Stefan Leitl irgendwann nicht mehr genug. Er ist ein sehr ambitionierter Trainer und er wollte nicht wieder einen Neuaufbau starten. Er musste in der Bundesliga schon einen Neuaufbau starten. Das haben wir in der Schlusskonferenz damals oft besprochen. Das ist in der Rückrunde auch ganz gut geklappt hat. Aber es war dann eigentlich relativ früh klar, dass er sich aus Fürth verabschieden wird. Asusi hat ihm dann zwar noch mal relativ spät einen 3-Jahres-Vertrag angeboten. Aber eigentlich war da schon – nach allem, was man jetzt hört, da spricht niemand offen drüber – war schon längst klar, dass Stefan Leitl dieses Angebot niemals annehmen wird, weil er auch jetzt nach dem Abstieg ein erneuter Neuaufbau gestartet werden musste. Und jetzt hat sich Leitl nach Hannover verabschiedet. Aber dann war lange die Frage, wer kommt nach Fürth? Es sind viele Namen gefallen. Es sind auch Namen kursiert wie Martin de Micheles oder Miroslav Klose. Aber eigentlich in Fürth dringt sehr, sehr wenig nach außen. Und ich erinnere mich noch sehr gut an diesen Tag. Ich saß am Laptop und auf einmal kam die Meldung aus der Schweiz. Es kam auf Mark Schneider, wird neuer Trainer der Spielvereinigung. Und da habe ich mir damals gedacht, okay, wer ist dieser Mensch? Ich habe dann einfach mal angerufen in der Schweiz bei verschiedenen Medien und habe mir ein bisschen was erzählen lassen. Das klang dann sehr, sehr gut. Man hat ja einen Trainer geholt, der mit dem kleinen FC Thun in der Schweiz unter anderem mal 3. Platz wurde, der auch in der EuroLeague-Quali damals gespielt hat. Also mit so einem kleinen Verein viel geschafft hat, der – so hieß es, dann haben mir Schweizer Journalisten erzählt – der es schafft, aus einem Kollektiv etwas zu schaffen, das mehr wert ist als die Summe der Einzelteile. Und dass das Klang alles sehr, sehr nachführt, also dass man aus bescheidenen Mitteln sehr viel macht. Deswegen kann man auch verstehen, warum da Mark Schneider sehr weit oben stand auf der Liste von Rashida Sousi. Und das ließ sich auch sehr gut an. Man hat in der Vorbereitung gute Spiele gezeigt. Man hat gegen den FC Basel sehr gut ausgesehen. Man hat gegen Jankos Bern, also zwei Schweizer Spitzenmannschaften, gut ausgesehen. Und man hat ja auch am ersten Spieltag daran, wenn sich einige Menschen erinnern, sehr gut ausgesehen. Man hat gegen Holstein Kiel gespielt. Da gab es ja vor einigen Tagen auf Twitter eine Kontroverse über die Expected Goals, weil Fürth da 4, 0 irgendwas hatte. Laut Bundesligas Expected Goals, am Ende war der Expected Goalswert nicht so hoch. Aber laut anderen Anbietern im Mittel war er nicht so hoch. Aber man hatte 24 zu 4 Torschüsse gegen Holstein Kiel. Und alle dachten sich, dieses Fürth, die spielen dieses Jahr wieder weit oben mit. Tja, man hat nicht gewonnen. Es ging 2 zu 2 aus. Und dann begann ein sehr, sehr steiler Abstieg nach diesem Spiel. Also man dachte, es ist alles super in Fürth. Und in den Wochen danach wurde nur noch wenig super. Wenn man nur die Spiele mal durchgeht. Man hat dann in Nürnberg gespielt, die erste Halbzeit. Man weiß ja jetzt nach der Hinterrunde, wie gut der 1. Halbzeit in Nürnberg ist. Und Fürth war einfach wirklich schlecht in dieser ersten Halbzeit. Und man hat dann auch beide Halbzeiten gegen den Club verloren. Also man hat in beiden Halbzeiten Gegentor kassiert. Auch wenn in Fürth viele dann noch gesagt haben, man hätte die 2. Halbzeit dominiert. Aber man hat eben kein Tor gemacht. Man hat auch gegen den Club nochmal eins kassiert. Man hat das Derby dann verloren. Das war für Fürth natürlich schon mal – Derbys gegen Nürnberg hat man in den letzten Jahren eigentlich immer gewonnen. Oder sehr, sehr häufig gewonnen. Das war dann auch nicht gut. Und dann war die Stimmung da schon relativ schlecht. Das haben auch immer wieder viele betont, dass es in Fürth erstaunlich schnell, erstaunlich negativ wurde. Dann hat man im Pokal noch gegen die Stuttgarter Kickers verloren. Und ich erinnere mich dann noch sehr gut an ein Gespräch mit einem Co-Trainer und Spielanalysten eines Zweitligisten, der dieses Spiel verfolgt hat, den ich schon länger kenne. Und der dann sagte, was macht diese Mannschaft auf dem Platz? Also man hat da keinerlei Struktur mehr gesehen. Es war wirklich extrem schlecht. Man hat gegen den Fünfligisten die Stuttgarter Kickers 2-0 verloren. Auch das ist schlimm, ist schwer zu sagen. Aber sie haben verdient gegen den Fünfligisten verloren. Und dann hat man in der Woche darauf gegen den Karlsruher SC auch nicht gewonnen. Da kann man dann über Schiedsrichterentscheidungen sprechen. Aber man hat dann eben auch nicht gewonnen. Und wenn man dann weiterblickt, man muss nicht jedes Spiel einzeln durchgehen. Aber man hat dann einfach nicht mehr gewonnen. Und man hat erst gegen den SC Paderborn gewonnen. Da war die Stimmung schon sehr, sehr schlecht. Da hatte man schon gegen Magdeburg verloren. Ich hatte damals dann auch schon geschrieben, dass Marc Scheyder entlassen werden müsste. Rashida Sousi hat sich entschieden, ihm noch mal ein Spiel zu geben. Das war dann erst im September, Mitte September, dass man gegen den Paderborn gewonnen hat. Und es blieb dann auch der einzige Sieg unter Marc Scheyder. Als Fürth sollte man meinen, müsste man gegen Rostock, Sandhausen und Regensburg die bessere Mannschaft sein. Aber Fürth war selbst gegen Regensburg die schlechtere Mannschaft spielerisch. Man hat so ängstlich Angst erfüllt gespielt, auch wenn man so den PPDA-Wert anschaut. Das Spiel gegen Lautern ist schon gefallen vorhin. Da hatte Fürth einen PPDA-Wert von knapp fünf. Man hat da auch noch sehr aggressiv angelaufen. Man hat versucht, das Spiel zu dominieren. Und später gegen Paderborn, das war dann der Höhepunkt, in Anführungszeichen der Negativität. Das war dem Ergebnis nach gut. Aber man hat Paderborn eben 20 Ballbesitzaktionen gelassen. Der PPDA-Wert war bei 20. Und das war sehr, sehr abwartend, war nicht Fürth-typisch. Man hat dieses Spiel gewonnen, 2 zu 1 gegen Paderborn, mit einem sehr, sehr defensiven Ansatz. Aber in den Wochen danach wurde es wieder schlechter. Man hat dann einfach kein Spiel, diese drei Spiele gegen Rostock, Sandhausen und Regensburg gewonnen. Und gegen Rostock war es natürlich dann – vielleicht war es die Fürth-typische Trainerentlassung, die es dann geben konnte, weil ich fand, der Zeitpunkt war schon viel früher reif, um den Trainer zu tauschen. Und man hat ihn dann entlassen nach einem Spiel gegen Rostock, wo man 2 zu 1 führt, wo man eine Kontersituation hat kurz vor Ende, wo Afimiko Polullu den Ball aus zwei Metern, würde ich sagen, zehn Meter übers leere Tor schießt und dann in der Nachspielzeit einen strittigen Elfmeter zugesprochen bekommt, also bekam die Rostocker zugesprochen, und spielt dann auch 2 zu 2, und dann hat man Mark Schneider entlassen. Sehr glücklos, 13 Spiele, ein Sieg, sehr angsterfüllte Spielweise, kaum Spieler besser geworden, sehr viele Spieler sich zurückentwickelt, da muss man jetzt nicht über alle Namen sprechen, aber es war tatsächlich krass zu sehen, sportlich wirklich degeneriert, das war spielerisch echt schlecht am Ende, und dann kam Alexander Zorniger. Ja, und was seitdem passiert ist, das würde wahrscheinlich einen eigenen Podcast füllen, aber jetzt hat man dann gesehen… Ihr könnt ja hören, der Vierter Flachpass, aber tatsächlich war es dann so, dass diese Mannschaft doch nicht so schlecht ist, wie manche dachte. Selbst in Fürth hieß es irgendwann, vielleicht ist diese Mannschaft auch gar nicht so gut, wie man am Anfang dachte. Und jetzt sieht man eben in diesen vier Spielen unter Zorniger, dass sie dann doch ziemlich gut ist, wenn sie einen Trainer hat, der einen klaren Plan hat, der auch erstaunlich schnell die Psyche wieder aufgerichtet hat. Wenn man da mit Spielern gesprochen hat, die waren wirklich alle komplett konsterniert, sie wussten auch nicht mehr, was ist da eigentlich passiert. Und Zorniger hat es dann geschafft mit diesem Sieg gegen Bielefeld. Eva erinnert sich wahrscheinlich leidvoll. Das war schon gut.
Nee, gar nicht.
Nee, gar nicht. Das war schon gut. Und man hat jetzt wirklich unter Zorniger in jedem Spiel Fortschritte gesehen. Und das finde ich schon krass. Also er ist jetzt seit drei Wochen da. Er war bei diesem Spiel in Heidenheim auf der Tribüne, was auch wieder witzig war, weil es noch nicht damals noch nicht klar war, dass Zorniger der neue Trainer wird. Alle haben so ein bisschen rumgeeiert. Und dann dachte ich mir, ich halte in Heidenheim die Augen offen. Das war ja das Spiel, das man mit einem Interimstrainer angegangen ist, mit Rainer Wiedmeier. Und ich dachte mir, ich halte mal die Augen offen. Die Haupttribüne in Heidenheim ist ja sehr, sehr klein. Und auf einmal läuft dann Alexander Zorniger mit Jurek Rohrberg, den man ja auch noch als Sky-Moderator kennt, der Zornigers persönlicher Assistent ist, einfach in der Reihe hinter mir vorbei und mussten warten, weil mein Rucksack noch in der Reihe stand. Also das war Reporter-Glück, würde ich es nennen, dass dann der neue Trainer einfach in Heidenheim in mir vorbei läuft. Aber was er in diesen drei Wochen geschafft hat, das war ja eine englische Woche, ist wirklich krass zu sehen. Also Bielefeld war gut, Braunschweig die erste Halbzeit war auch richtig gut. Auswärts hat man auch 1 zu 0 gewonnen. Das Spiel gegen den HSV fand ich das Beste. Aber insgesamt dafür, dass man dann auswärts gespielt hat am vergangenen Sonntag in Darmstadt, dass man da Darmstadt, die wirklich nicht viele Torchancen zulassen, die auch defensiv eigentlich solide stehen, dass man da zur Pause 3-1 führen könnte und dann halt am Ende bitter die Geldbrote Karte bekommt in der 48. Minute, aber das dann auch noch in Unterzahl so gut verteidigt nach so einer Hinrunde und dann auch noch gegen den Spitzenreiter einen Punkt holt und jetzt in der Zorniger-Tabelle, die ja schon oft zitiert wurde, auf Platz 3 ist aber nur aufgrund der schlechteren Tordifferenz. Das ist dann schon wirklich krass zu sehen nach diesem ganzen Fußballjahr aus vierter Sicht. Also wenn man die ganzen Zahlen nochmal des Jahres anschaut, das ist auch krass, sechs Siege in einem ganzen Jahr, aber halt dann drei Siege unter Alexander Zorniger von diesen sechs in den letzten drei Wochen. Also ich war lange, ich habe mich wirklich schwergetan. Der Job war nicht schön aufgrund dieser ganzen Negativität, aber jetzt muss man sagen, Zorniger, ich hatte am Montag ein Interview mit ihm und da hat er gesagt, er hatte auch Zweifel und die Viertel hatten sicher auch Zweifel, ob sie den Zorniger holen sollen, hat er gesagt. Und seine Conclusio stand jetzt haben beide Parteien alles richtig gemacht. Und das ist wahrscheinlich das, was die letzten drei Wochen Fürth perfekt zusammenfasst. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass Fürth jetzt, wenn es so gut weitergeht und man von Verletzungen verschont bleibt, nicht bis zum 34. Spieltag wird zittern müssen um den Klassenverbleib.
Also die Hälfte der Punkte hat man unter Alexander Zorniger geholt. Zehn der 20 Punkte. Und nur um nochmal zu verdeutlichen, wo Fürth herkommt. Also wer die vergangene Kurzpässe gehört hat, der hat das schon mitbekommen allein atmosphärisch. Aber an neun Spieltagen von insgesamt Jahr 17 lag man auf einem der letzten drei Plätze. Und jetzt eben, also wir sprechen auch zum perfekten Zeitpunkt, Michi. Das muss man echt so sagen. Also man stand nur einmal noch besser, nämlich am neunten Spieltag in der englischen Woche. Da war es nämlich auch dann der Tabellenplatz neun. Also wirklich erstaunlich, was sich da verändert hat und welchen Impact da Alexander Zorniger hatte. Und ich habe gehört, dass Eva sich schon entmuted hatte. Deswegen habe ich das Gefühl, du möchtest da noch etwas ergänzen.
Nee, ich finde es halt, erstens habe ich so das Gefühl, gerade so der letzte Teil, ich habe das jetzt in letzter Zeit sehr oft in verschiedenen Sprachen von Michi gehört, ich hätte es ungefähr so paraforsieren können. Denn es saßen genug Podcasts in der letzten Zeit. Ich fand es, ja, was heißt amüsant, aber ich finde es ganz interessant, als Michi bei uns im Podcast war, das war eben nach dem 1-0 gegen Bielefeld. Und da haben wir beide gesagt, ja, das, was diese Liga bis jetzt gezeigt hat, ist, dass ein Sieg überhaupt nichts bringt. Man muss eigentlich so eine Serie aufbauen. Oder zumindest mal zwei Siege in Folge gewinnen. Zwei Spiele in Folge gewinnen, um Himmels willen. Und das hat man halt dann gesehen. Was so ein kleiner Run alleine auch ausmachen kann, sowohl positiv als auch negativ, wenn man zum Beispiel auf den SD. Paderborn guckt, der ja viele Spiele in Folge verloren hat und jetzt halt auch nicht mal unter den ersten drei ist. So hätten wir doch vor drei Wochen darüber gesprochen. Ganz anderer Tabellenplatz wäre ja auch mit in dieser Runde gewesen. Und das, wenn ich – also das hat halt führt, anders als vielleicht auch andere Vereine, einfach gut geschafft, da einfach wirklich mal so eine Reihe aufzubauen, gerade auch defensiv, wie wichtig das ist, weil man dann eben sagt, ja, ist dann auch egal, wie viele Torschüsse wir zugelassen haben, aber wir haben halt eben kein Gegentor kassiert. Dass man gegen Darmstadt halt so früh eins kassiert, ist halt einfach ungünstig. Aber sonst, ja, es ist halt gerade defensiv auch wirklich irgendwie mit Michalski, der dann natürlich auch vorne ganz gut treffen kann. Ich glaube, was auch wichtig war, ist, dass man eben ja vielleicht jetzt doch mit Amindo Sieb irgendwie mal einen Stürmer gefunden hat, neben Hukkota, der da irgendwie wirklich nochmal Tore machen könnte. Das war ja irgendwie davor okay, wenn man irgendwie einigermaßen Tore schießen will, muss es halt irgendwie Hukkota machen. Und sonst halt irgendjemand, dann war es irgendwie Michalski ein paar Spiele durch Kopfball. Aber es hat ja irgendwie so richtig von den Neuverpflichtungen dieser eine Spieler gefehlt, der dann vielleicht auch mal ein Tor machen kann. Da war ja irgendwie so ein Rennen immer zwischen Acha auch und Sieb, und das hat irgendwie immer alles nicht so geklappt. Aber ich glaube, mit Sieb, der jetzt eben auch in den drei von vier Spielen getroffen hat, wenn ich mich da nicht irre, ist das auf jeden Fall auch ein großer Gewinn für Fürth. Und wie gesagt, ich glaube, Fürth hat halt gezeigt, wie wichtig es ist, dass es auch egal sein kann, wie du in den, weiß ich nicht, zehn, 13 Spielen davor gespielt hast, wenn du es schaffst, einfach deine Gegner hinter dich zu lassen, gegen direkte Konkurrenten zu gewinnen und halt so ein Bonusspiel, sage ich jetzt mal, gegen den HSV zu gewinnen und dann halt auch ein Punkt gegen Darmstadt, dann kann so eine Lage ganz anders aussehen, was halt gleichzeitig auch wirklich nochmal für diese Liga, also was das jetzt aussagt, kann man jetzt positiv oder negativ sagen, was aber gleichzeitig auch bedeutet, dass man, glaube ich, einfach wirklich gerade in dieser Saison ganz, ganz schwierig nur sagen kann, wer wo endet am Ende, weil es halt einfach zwei Ergebnisse können so eine komplette Tabelle wirklich mehr durcheinanderbringen als vielleicht in der Bundesliga, aber das war halt in den letzten Jahren auch schon immer so, aber gerade auch im Abstiegskampf Ich finde, der Kampf ist um einiges enger, weil es sehr viel Bewegung gibt und es eben nicht mehr ganz klar diesen letzten Platz gibt. Ich meine, drei Vereine haben 17 Punkte und stehen da irgendwie alle drin. Das war in den letzten Jahren definitiv nicht so.
Das ist auch etwas, was Alexander Zornigge am Sonntag in Darmstadt erzählte. Er fand es sogar womöglich mit Blick aufs große Ganze sogar ganz gut, dass man da eigentlich auch noch gewonnen hat in Darmstadt. Ich habe vorhin die negative Stimmung angesprochen, die ist sehr schnell ins Positive umgeschlagen. Auch weil Zornigge natürlich ein Menschenfänger ist, der schon bei seiner ersten Pekadi-Fans mitgenommen hat, der sie gelobt hat nach dem Bielefeld-Spiel, dass sie das Fancy-Spiel mitgewonnen hätten. Er hat das schon auch sehr klug gemacht. Dieser Trainer ist in allen Facetten bislang perfekt. Er passt perfekt zu Fürth, er ist ein Gewinn für Fürth. Aber er hat auch gesagt, wenn du gewonnen hättest in Darmstadt auch noch, hätte Fürth 22 Punkte und dann hätten die Ersten schon nach oben geschaut. Das ist ja gar nicht mal so zu unrecht, denn der erste Paderborn, den Eva gerade angesprochen hat, der damals, als er nach Fürth kam, gefühlt noch Lichtjahre entfernt war, wäre nur noch vier Punkte entfernt gewesen. Und er sagte, man muss schon auch wachsam bleiben in dieser Liga, was natürlich eine trügerische Sicherheit ist. Also Fürth hat zehn Punkte geholt aus vier Spielen, hat aber halt vier Punkte Vorsprung auf den Tabellen 18. Und drei auf den direkten Abstiegsplatz. Also wenn der Start ins neue Jahr schlecht ausgeht, dann kann man halt auch immer wieder 18er sein als Tabellenzehnte und das ist natürlich extrem schwierig. Aber wenn ich jetzt so den Vergleichsmaßstab der 2. Bundesliga sehe, also ich denke in der Gänze habt ihr alle drei wahrscheinlich, oder zumindest Tim und Eva, mehr Zweitligaspiele gesehen an Minuten. Aber ich habe jetzt jeden Gegner einmal live im Stadion gesehen und klar, gibt es dann Mannschaften, die haben einen schlechten Tag. Aber wenn Fürth so spielt, wie sie derzeit spielen und wenn sie das konservieren können, wenn der Spielstil so bleibt, wenn Michalski in Fürth bleibt, das können wir gleich noch mal drüber sprechen ganz kurz, also dieser Transfer ist für mich der beste, den Fürth getätigt hat. Aber dann kann Fürth wirklich da, dann muss man halt auch gegen in der Rückrunde, die Spiele, die eng waren, diese 50-50-Spiele, man hat ja auch gar nicht so oft verloren Fürth. Also das gehört ja auch dazu, man hat ja einfach sieben, näher jetzt an mit Darmstadt, acht unentschiedene in 17 Spielen. Wenn man diese 50-50-Spiele, von denen man genug hätte gewinnen können, wenn man die noch gewinnt in der Rückrunde gegen direkte Konkurrenz, dann kann man die auch relativ gut distanzieren. Und ja, dieses Thema Stürmer ist in Fürth schon eines, also auch zu Beginn der Saison. Ragnar Acher hat jetzt dann zwei Tore gemacht als Stürmer, der mit die meisten Minuten gespielt hat. Herr Goda ist halt wieder mal gut, aber er spielt jetzt eben unter Zornic immer in diesem 3-1, 3-5-2, 3-4-1-2, diese Zehnerposition. Und er kommt da eben nicht zum Abschluss, weil er ein Spieler ist, der sehr viel zwischen den Linien schwimmt, der sich oftmals fallen lässt. Und er ist halt dann eben nicht mehr da, wo er sein müsste. Also ich habe letztens auch mal in einem Podcast gesagt, Fürth bräuchte eben ein zweiter Gota, dass er auch für Gota in der Spitze spielen könnte, weil er ist ein so spielintelligenter Spieler. Aber dadurch, dass er halt einfach alles machen will und überall zu finden sein will und sich auch dem, sagen wir mal, dem Zugriff entziehen will der gegnerischen Ketten, lässt er sich eben oft fallen. Und dadurch ist er einfach nicht mehr da, wo er sein muss. Und das ist schon ein Problem am Mindusieb. Ja, ist jetzt schön, er hat drei Tore gemacht, hat dreimal das 1-0 erzielt und das hat für neun Punkte gereicht. Das ist ja auch so eine Geschichte für diese Saison. Aber ansonsten ist es echt schwierig an Stürmern. Dix na Biama ist also diese traurige Geschichte. Also alle Fans der 2. Bundesliga kennen noch diese märchenhafte Story, als er im Aufstiegsjahr so kam. Die wurde ja auch auf Skype von den Reportern rauf und runter erzählt. Diese Geschichte von der Kreisklasse, also der drittletzten Liga, so nach oben gearbeitet und dann ohne jemals ein ÖZ gesehen zu haben. Der beste Joker im Aufstiegsjahr mit sieben Toren. Der hat halt eben gegen Düsseldorf beim Aufstiegsspiel zum letzten Mal getroffen. Weder in der Bundesliga noch jetzt in der Hinrunde. So die tragische Figur. Aber zur Wahrheit gehört eben auch, dass Fürth bereit war, Geld auszugeben. Man hatte in der Bundesliga Jessica Nankam von der Hertha geliehen. Den wollte man auch kaufen, hätte dafür auch einiges an Geld auf den Tisch gelegt. Aber die Hertha hat dann die Rückkaufoption gezogen. Und man wollte auch Havard Nielsen noch länger halten. Das sieht man jetzt auch. Bei Hannover hat sieben Tore gemacht und ein extrem kopfbar starker Spieler. Also wenn ich mir jetzt denke, es wären Nankam und Nielsen noch da. Ich denke, Fürth hätte mehr Tore geschossen, hätte wohl wirklich auch diese 50-50 Spiele mehrmals gewonnen. Ja, es ist wie es ist. Die ersten 13 Spiele waren wirklich extrem hart, teilweise auch hart anzusehen. Aber jetzt gerade steht Fürth wirklich gut da. Und ja, also Damian Michalski, wenn wir noch kurz auf die Transfers kommen, kam ja auch relativ spät. Also er kam erst, als die Saison schon lief. Das gehört eben auch zur Wahrheit, dass Fürth aufgrund des Ausfalls von Sebastian Griesbeck, der ja als Innenverteidiger gespielt hat, eben drei Spiele mit einem jungen Spieler namens Oliver Fubasam gespielt hat, den niemand vorher kannte, der aus der U19 des VfL Wolfsburg kam. Man hat eben auch gesehen, dass dieser Spieler aus der U19 des VfL Wolfsburg kam. Er hatte in der Rückgründe unter Leitl schon mit trainiert in der Bundesliga, hat aber kein Spiel gemacht und musste dann eben drei Spiele in der Startelf spielen. Das hat unter anderem in Düsseldorf einen Elfmeter verursacht. Das gehört auch zu der Wahrheit. Dann hat man eben sehr spät Damian Michalski geholt, der seitdem auch alle Spiele fast durchgespielt hat und vier Tore gemacht hat. Er ist der zweitbeste Torschütze dieser vierten Mannschaft. Das sagt auch schon sehr vieles aus. Wenn man das in Darmstadt gesehen hat, wie er sich gegen drei Darmstädter bei einer Ecke durchgesetzt hat, bei Darmstadt, wo wir darüber gesprochen haben, wie stark sie bei Standards sind. Offensive Standards mehr. Aber dieser Spieler hat auch ganz klar bei seiner Ankunft schon gesagt, dass er Fürth als Zwischenstation sieht. Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass da im Winter schon die ersten Anfragen kommen. Die werden im nächsten Sommer natürlich nochmal kommen. Das wäre dann für Fürth wieder ein Spieler, wo man Geld verdienen kann, aber wo man natürlich auch sehr, sehr viel defensive Stabilität aufgeben würde. Deshalb gehe ich davon aus, dass er nicht im Winter verkaufen wird, außer es ist ein unmoralisches Angebot in so einer Höhe, wo man sagt, okay, da kann ich nicht Nein sagen.
Was hat sich jetzt in Fürth eigentlich geändert? Ich habe die letzten drei Spiele auch gesehen von Fürth und ich habe davor auch einige Spiele von denen gesehen. Ist das nur diese Umstellung auf den 5-3-2 von Zorniger gewesen oder was hat sich da noch geändert?
Diese Umstellung ist schon signifikant, weil man jetzt eben mit diesen drei Innenverteidigern, Grisbeck, Michalski und Hadadi, spielt, die ganz unterschiedliche Typen sind. Michalski ist mit dem Ball am Fuß jetzt keine Augen weiter, aber er ist extrem physisch stark, gewinnt alle Kopfball-Duelle. Man hat das auch gegen Bielefeld gesehen, wie Fabian Kloss irgendwann einfach angewidert schon fast geschaut hat, weil er sich dachte, ich habe keinen Bock mehr gegen diesen Spieler zu spielen, weil er jedes Kopfball-Duell einfach verloren hat. Und Bielefeld hat ja nur mit diesen weiten Bällen gespielt. Hadadi, ein sehr erfahrener Spieler, war ja auch schon ein thunesischer Nationalspieler, der sehr abgeklärt spielt, der sich im Spielaufbau sehr weit nach vorne einschaltet. Und das kann er eben in dieser Dreikette sehr viel besser. Und auch Marco Mayhöfer, das ist ja auch eine Geschichte, Knöchelbruch in der Bundesliga ist zurückgekommen, hat zwei Spiele gespielt, als wäre er nie weg gewesen. Der darf auch sehr viel offensiver verteidigen, weil mit Grießberg eine Absicherung hinter ihm da ist. Also auch Marco Ion auf der linken Seite, der ist 20 Jahre alt, von der TSG Hoffenheim gelehen, in den letzten Spielen wahnsinnig gut gespielt. Und dieses 3-5-2 kommt eben sehr vielen Spielertypen mit diesem Kader sehr, sehr entgegen, weil man sehr weit nach vorne verteidigen kann, weil man aber auch mit dieser immer noch Dreikette hinten extreme Stabilität hat, auch eine gute Geschwindigkeit. Das haben ja auch einige Zweitelegisten nicht, diese Geschwindigkeit. Zu Griesbeck, das denkt man nicht, wenn man ihn sieht, aber er ist halt auch ein guter Sprinter. Also man hat eben wirklich diese drei Spielertypen in der Dreikette. Das sind für mich eine der drei Garanten für diesen Erfolg. Man sieht aber auch, was passiert, wenn einer dieser Spielertypen ausfällt, dann hat man dahinter nicht mehr viel. Man hat Gideon Jung eben noch. Und jetzt sagt er auch Zornigge, der Spielermaterial – ich mag dieses Wort ja nicht – aber er ist nicht dafür ausgelegt, permanent Dreikette zu spielen, weil wenn einer ausfällt, tut man sich schwer, das aufzufangen. Deshalb bin ich sehr gespannt, wie Fürth die Rückgründe angeht. Aber ganz klar ist ja, dass man sehr viel höher presst, sehr viel aggressiver presst, dass man den Gegner permanent stresst und dadurch eben schon sehr viele Gegner beschäftigt. Also, wie ich vorhin sagte, hat Fürth sehr abwartend und passiv gespielt, hat sich dann irgendwann hinten reindringen lassen. Und jetzt eben mit Ion und Mayhöfer oder auch Astah, der eine gute Entwicklung genommen hat, hat man eben da auch auf Links- und Rechtsspieler, die es sehr gerne sehr weit hochschieben, die auch fußballerisch gut sind. So bei Lösungen ins letzte Drittel, vor allem Mayhöfer, ist da eben ein sehr kluger, sehr spielintegenter Spieler. Also ich würde sagen, die Ansprache von Zorniger, aber auch auf jeden Fall diese Umstellung auf dieses 3-5-2-5-3-2, je nachdem, wie man es interpretiert, ist schon der größte Knackpunkt und die größte Stellschraube, wie Trainer sagen würde, der Zorniger gedreht hat. Und ich hätte es nie erwartet, aber dass diese Mannschaft auch eine ist, die dafür gemacht ist, so hoch anzulaufen. Man sieht jetzt gerade, dass es Spielertypen gibt, von denen man dachte, dass die Schlüsselspieler sind, wie Julien Green zum Beispiel oder auch Jeremy Dudziak, die einfach gar keine Rolle mehr spielen. Und dafür spielt er jetzt Tobias Raschl als dieser offensivere Part auf der Doppel-Sex mit Max Christianzen eine sehr viel wichtigere Rolle. Und man sieht jetzt auch, dass es eben nicht nur hohes Anlaufen ist. In Darmstadt hat man auch gesehen, dass Fürth unter Zorniger mit dem Ball sehr gute Lösungen hatte. Man hatte viele Positionswechsel im Angriffsspiel, einige Verlagerungen. Es ist noch nicht alles perfekt, aber jetzt Zorniger fängt schon am 4. Dezember wieder an, weil er so viel noch verändern will. Also, ich bin sehr, sehr gespannt, aber bislang sieht es sehr, sehr gut aus. Und ich tue mich noch schwer, das alles zu erklären. Deswegen ist die Frage von Tim berechtigt. Aber ich denke, dieses 532-352 ist schon der größte Schlüssel gewesen.
Dann sind wir mal sehr gespannt, wie das weitergeht unter Alex Zorniger. Er hat es ja immerhin schon mal geschafft mit einem Zitat in die Hinrundenbilanz der ersten Männer-Bundesliga. Das muss man auch erstmal hinbekommen. Er gibt einfach launige Pressekonferenzen. Ich glaube, das macht dann auch als Reporter Spaß, mit so einem Trainer zusammenzuarbeiten, so wie man eben zusammenarbeitet mit den Protagonisten dieses Sports. Wir haben noch immer noch vier Teams, über die wir sprechen wollen. Nein, es sind sogar fünf. Deswegen müssen wir vielleicht ein bisschen im Tempo anziehen, je nachdem, wie bei euch die Zeitlichkeit aussieht. Lasst mal über Eintracht Braunschweig sprechen. Das ist ein weiterer Aufsteiger. Und jetzt kommen wir in die Tabellenregion. Also noch klarer als gerade mit Fürth, wo du ja schon richtigerweise auf die drei Punkte Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz hingewiesen hast. Braunschweig hat auf Rang 14 liegend nur einen Punkt Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz. Tim, was ist denn Braunschweig für ein Aufsteiger? Wir haben ja schon bei Casas Lautern darüber gesprochen. Kein typischer Aufsteiger und haben ein bisschen auseinandergedröset. Was unterscheidet dieses Team von anderen? Wie sieht es denn bei der Eintracht aus?
Ja, also ein bisschen typischer als auf jeden Fall Magdeburg, würde ich mal sagen. Braunschweig ist ein Team, das unter Michael Schiele fast, ja doch ziemlich wenig geändert hat am Spielstil, der sie zum Aufstieg gebracht hat. Die sind tatsächlich mit so einem Fokus auf Umschaltmomente aufgestiegen und haben das auch weiter fortgeführt. Dieses enorme Tempo, was sie dann gebracht haben, also mit einer Dreierkette und daraus dann Umschalten. Mit Uca als Stürmer haben sie sich mit Sicherheit auch einen Spieler geholt, der da ziemlich gut reinpasst. Mit Immanuel Ferrai haben sie sich eins der mit kreativsten und spannendsten Spieler der Liga oder Indie-Liga geholt von Dortmund 2. Die hatten zwischendurch eine Phase, da waren sie enorm stark. Die haben acht Spiele in Folge nicht verloren und haben jetzt aber am Ende – jetzt kann man es auch wieder umdrehen, weil die letzten beiden Spiele dieser ungeschlagenen Serie waren zwei unentschieden – jetzt kann man es umdrehen, sie haben auch wieder fünf Spiele in Folge nicht gewonnen. Sie hatten zwischendurch einen Hoch, da sind sie dann sogar fast bis in die erste Tabellenhälfte gekommen, haben sie dann aber nicht ganz geschafft, hingen dann irgendwo auf Platz 11 fest und sind jetzt doch wieder auf Platz 14 abgerutscht. Das ist ja unfassbar eng da zwischen Platz 8, 9 und Platz 18. Also es kann total schnell in beide Richtungen gehen. Das war bei Braunschweig nicht anders zu erwarten, dass die so eine Saison spielen werden. Ich finde es aber bemerkenswert, wie krass sie dann doch diesen Fußball weiter spielen. Die haben mit Benkovic und Demidina zwei Defensivleute mit ins Team geholt, die da ziemlich gut reinpassen. Benkovic ist ein wahnsinnig kopfballstarker Spieler. Und vorne eben mit Feray und Uca zwei Spieler rein geholt, die da doch zu diesem Fußball von Chile passen. Und eine Zahl kann ich dazu auch noch liefern, wenn ich beschreibe, was für ein Fußball die spielen, dann sind es eben die Sprints zum Beispiel. Also wenn man sagt, die sind umschaltstark, dann muss man davon ausgehen, dass die auch sprintsstark sind. Braunschweig läuft nicht so viel, liefert auch nicht so viele intensive Läufe, aber sie liefern eben viele Sprints. Da liegen sie auf Platz drei und das zeigt eben dieses Umschaltspiel relativ gut. Das sieht man auch an den Pässen. Sie spielen viele Pässe ins letzte Drittel, viele lange Pässe, aber die Quoten sind eher mittelmäßig. Das ist relativ risikoarm, aber sie versuchen schnellstmöglich nach vorne zu kommen. Sie hatten zwischendurch eine Phase, wo sie auch den FC St. Pauli geschlagen haben, wo sie damit ganz gut zurechtgekommen sind gegen Magdeburg, die ja sehr viel auf Ballbesitz setzen. Sie hatten dann zuletzt Teams wie Regensburg, Rostock, Sandhausen, die vielleicht selber auch eine – wie fasse ich das mal zusammen – eine ballbesitzferne Spielidee haben. So würde ich das mal nennen. Da könnte es sein, dass man selber dann vielleicht ein bisschen mehr gefordert war und nicht diese eigene Umschaltidee umsetzen konnte, so wie geplant. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen vermutet. Ich persönlich muss dazu sagen, ich habe Eintracht Braunschweig ein bisschen schwächer erwartet in der Saison und bin doch positiv überrascht worden, wie gut da die Abläufe zwischendurch liefen. Die sind dann ja auch im Grunde gestartet, wie ich sie erwartet habe. Die haben in den ersten vier Spielen gar nicht getroffen und alle vier Spiele verloren. Dann haben sie sich aber richtig reingearbeitet in die 2. Bundesliga. Das wird auf jeden Fall noch eine spannende Rückrunde für die.
Die haben die drittschwächste Offensive der Liga nur an den Toren gemessen hinter Nürnberg und Rostock, aber immerhin haben sie aus 18 Treffern dann auch 18 Punkte gemacht. Ein Punkt pro Treffer, wenn das so weitergeht, dann kann das noch funktionieren. Eva, wie gefällt dir denn Braunschweig?
Ja, also ich glaube, gerade zu den letzten Spielen muss man halt auch wirklich sehen, dass Braunschweig zum Beispiel auch wie Sandhausen einfach großes Verletzungspech hatte. Also gerade, wenn Demedina und Berend defensiv auch ausfallen, also gerade Brian Berend ist ja – ich kenne ihn halt auch noch aus Bielefelder Zeiten – der ist halt schon defensiv ein wichtiger Faktor. Er kann offensiv aber auch richtig Richtung Standard, so Nistanzschüsse gefährlich werden und natürlich halt dadurch, dass er auf Reif verletzt war, hat man halt schon gemerkt, es fehlt halt was Kreatives vorne. Dann hat natürlich auch noch Uja zwei Spiele gefehlt oder beziehungsweise muss das eine Spiel abbrechen, weil der Rücken zugemacht hat. Das hat man halt eben schon gemerkt. Ich glaube, was für Braunschweig unfassbar wichtig war, ist, dass man nach der 4-1-Niederlage gegen Bielefeld das Spiel gegen Nürnberg dann gewonnen hat. Weil ich habe eben schon mal angesprochen, sowohl negativ als auch positive Serien kann halt richtig weh tun und hätte man halt mit zwei Niederlagen in Folge mit gemeinsamen Abstiegskandidaten das Derby vor der Brust gehabt, weiß ich jetzt auch nicht, wie das gelaufen wäre. Ich glaube, es war gerade, weil das ja wirklich auch so mittig in dieser Hinrunde war, da das 1-1 zu holen, hat mehr für Braunschweig bedeutet als für Hannover. Also im positiven Sinne. Es war halt auch einfach keine gute Leistung von Hannover, aber das war halt einfach, ja glaube ich, wichtig. Und dass man halt eben sich dann doch stabilisiert hat. Also man hätte ja durchaus auch Schiele. Ja, irgendwie, gerade wenn man ihn bei Sandhausen gesehen hat, da wurde er damals ja relativ schnell entlassen. Das war ja keine gute Phase für ihn. Hatte wahrscheinlich auch so ein bisschen Angst, dass ihm das wieder droht, aber hatte da wahrscheinlich auch eben diesen Ausstiegskredit. Und viel läuft ja auch einfach gut bei denen. Wie gesagt, was natürlich für sie wichtig war, dass halt die Pause jetzt kommt, glaube ich, dass eben auch Spieler wie Feray oder eben halt auch die Defensivspieler, Demetina Berend eben zurückkommen können, Ujad dann auch irgendwie seine Rückenprobleme komplett auskurieren kann. Ich glaube einfach, ja, das ist, was bei denen auch ein Problem ist, ist das Thema Forsten- und Latten-Treffer. Also sie haben ja auch relativ, gerade im Anfang der Saison, sie hatten ja durchaus Möglichkeiten auch schon gegen den HSV. Also die Spiele waren ja nie so klar, wie es jetzt irgendwie bei 2-0 und 3-0 aussehen würde, sage ich mal, dass sie halt super viele Forsten-Treffer dabei haben. Auch ein Feray hat irgendwie vier der neun Forsten- und Latten-Treffer irgendwie verursacht, wenn man das so nennen kann. Ich glaube, das ist irgendwie dann auch schon durchaus frustrierend. Es gibt nur ein Team, das mehr Forsten-Treffer hat. Das ist Aminia.
Und auf Rang 3 übrigens der FC St. Pauli. Also ihr befindet euch hier in guter Gesellschaft.
Nein, aber generell würde ich auch zustimmen. Ich habe sie tatsächlich ein bisschen unsicherer erwartet, ein bisschen weiter unten in der Tabelle. Gleichzeitig, wie gesagt, glaube ich aber auch, dass die Pause gerade für Braunschweig zu einem richtigen Zeitpunkt kam, eben weil man dann das letzte Mal gegen Magdeburg gewonnen hat. Und das natürlich schon durchaus dann auch damit zu tun hat, dass Magdeburg ähnliche Probleme hat wie Braunschweig noch am Beginn der Saison. Dass man mit den Chancen, die man kreiert, einfach das nicht in Ergebnisse umwandeln kann. Aber was ich bei Braunschweig mal gespannt finde, ob sich das jetzt irgendwie in dieser Winterpause noch ein bisschen entwickelt, ist die Laufleistung. Da sind sie auf Platz 16 schon relativ gering. Gleichzeitig ist man bei Sprints auf Platz 3, finde ich auch immer eine interessante Kombination. Hat natürlich auch damit zu tun, dass man eben nicht so viel Beibesitz hat. Aber da bin ich mal gespannt, ob sich das auch irgendwie noch weiterentwickelt. Man hat eben auch die geringste Passquote der Liga. Also das ist halt auch definitiv was, was man, glaube ich, mal verbessern sollte, weil das natürlich auch oftmals den Gegner irgendwie einlädt. Aber generell bin ich gespannt, wo dieser Weg da noch hinführt. Ich würde auch mitgehen, dass für Rhein ein sehr interessanter Spieler ist, der einen sehr eigenen Kopf hat, weil das kann manchmal helfen, dass man einfach dieses eine kreative Momentum hat durch einen Spieler wie Feray. Gleichzeitig gibt es auch Matchpläne für einen – also einen schon durchaus Hintergrund – und wenn da immer einer sagt, ne, ich mache jetzt das, was ich will, auch nicht effektiv. Aber ich glaube wirklich, gerade was die Aussteiger betrifft, ich hätte Magdeburg da nicht als den – ich meine, über die sprechen wir ja gleich auch – nicht als den Kandidaten gesehen, der da als letzter in dieser Ausstiegsriege ist. Ich finde es aber durchaus auch wirklich interessant, wie unterschiedlich sich die Aussteiger schlagen.
Eine kleine Anmerkung nur noch, ich habe dir schon alles gesagt, dankenswerterweise, aber auch bei den Braunschweigern sieht man ja, was ein guter Saisonstart ausmacht, was es ausmachen kann. Also dieses 0-2 gegen HSV liest sich erstmal okay. Also 2-0 gegen den HSV kann man als Aufsteiger zuhause verlieren. Aber auch nach Expected Goals waren sie da ja die bessere Mannschaft. Auch die Bundesliga.de Statistiken sind oftmals etwas hochgegriffen, aber sie hatten halt 3, 29 zu 1, 85 in diesem Spiel. Da steckt ja die Wahrheit auch nochmal drin, die ihr gerade angesprochen habt. Sie hatten da auch teilweise ein bisschen Pech im Abschluss. Und wenn man natürlich als Aufsteiger gegen den HSV gewinnt zum Saisonstart, dann verlebt man danach vielleicht eine 3 weitere Male. Das war wie ähnlich bei Fürth. Wenn man das erste Spiel gewinnt, dann kann so eine Saison auch anders laufen. Aber sie ist eben nicht anders gelaufen. Ich habe auch noch die Erinnerungen relativ frisch. Man hat schon ganz klar gemerkt, dass Varei als kreativer Geist fehlt. Und Uccia, das weitere Spiel, was Eva angesprochen hatte, musste gegen Fürth ja ausgewechselt werden, weil er diese Probleme mit dem Rücken hatte. Und da hat man dann schon gemerkt, da kam nicht mehr viel. Also Braunschweig hatte in der zweiten Hälfte den Ball, aber es kam eigentlich nur zwei, so halb Chancen, einen Kopfball dabei herum. Aber ansonsten sind sie da einfach nicht gefährlich geworden gegen eine Mannschaft, die dann doch abwartend gespielt hat. Also da sieht man, was zwei Spieler ausmachen können. Und ja, die Pause kommt ihnen wahrscheinlich sehr gelegen jetzt.
Ja, wie so für manches Team tatsächlich. Es war dann doch eine lange Hinrunde. Die war es auch für den FC St. Pauli. Der ist auf Rang 15, nur ein Punkt hinter Braunschweig. Immerhin nicht auf den letzten drei Plätzen. Das hat allerdings ausschließlich mit der Tordifferenz zu tun. Denn die kommenden drei Teams, über die wir sprechen werden, St. Pauli, Bielefeld und Magdeburg, haben alle 17 Punkte. Wir haben es ja vorhin schon angedeutet. Alles noch extrem eng da unten. Jetzt haben wir Tim ja schon vor gar nicht so langer Zeit miteinander über St. Pauli gesprochen. Da kann man viele Dinge nachhören. Das war am 11. Oktober, habe ich mal gerade nachgeguckt. Ach krass, doch schon einen Monat. Hätte ich gar nicht gedacht. Gefühlt war es irgendwie vorgestern. Was ist denn seitdem noch dazugekommen? Siege sind es ja nicht, leider.
Naja, zumindest hat man das Derby einmal gewonnen gegen den HSV.
Bestimmt, das war ja noch vor dem Derby, Entschuldigung, ja.
Ja, genau, das war der einzige Sieg. Danach hat man fünf Spiele in Folge nicht mehr gewonnen. St. Pauli hat umgestellt. Die haben tatsächlich auch ein 3-5-2 bzw. ein 5-3-2 darauf umgestellt. Dadurch haben sie defensiv Stabilität gewonnen. Sich vielleicht, das kann man nicht so genau definieren, wenn man das nur an der Toranzahl macht, dann wahrscheinlich schon. Dann haben sie so ein bisschen offensive Power verloren. Da muss man aber auch ehrlich sagen, die Durchschlagskraft in der Offensive fehlt schon die gesamte Saison über. Und das hängt höchstwahrscheinlich, das wird hoffentlich die Analyse ergeben, die jetzt auch im Winter stattfinden soll. Das wird höchstwahrscheinlich, liegt das auch einfach an den Spielern, die da sind, dass denen das fehlt. Vor der Saison sind ja Daniel Kofi, Tre und Guido Burgstaller gegangen. Simon Makinoch ist auch gegangen. Und Maximilian Ditken ist gegangen, die alle vorne drin waren. Und das sind eben mit Abstand, glaube ich, 85 Prozent der Tore der letzten Saison sind gegangen. Und da ist Johannes Eggestein dazugekommen und David Otto. David Otto hat letzte Saison, glaube ich, dreimal getroffen. Johannes Eggestein gar nicht. Der hat vor drei Jahren in Österreich eine Saison gehabt, in der er zwölfmal getroffen hat. Und das weiß ich so genau, weil ich mal nachgeschaut habe, wie die Stürmer des FC St. Pauli, die aktuellen überhaupt im Herrenbereich, mal Tore erzielt haben in einer Saison. Und das ist tatsächlich diese Saison von Johannes Ergestein, wo er zwölf Tore gemacht hat in Österreich. Das ist tatsächlich die einzige, die einer von den inzwischen ja fünf Stürmern, weil Lukas Daschner da hochgezogen wurde, einer von den fünf Stürmern vorweisen kann, wo die mal zweistellig getroffen haben. Also Etienne Aminido zum Beispiel hat selbst, der hat bei Borussia Dortmund in der Jugend gespielt, hat selbst da nie zweistellig getroffen in einer zweistelligen Anzahl in einer Saison. Igor Matanovic, ein riesengroßes Talent, der ist komplett im Tief, hat jetzt fast 50 Spiele, insgesamt drei Tore, das ist jetzt natürlich auch kein Bewerbungsschreiben, der wechselt zu Eintracht Frankfurt nach Saisonende. Da bin ich mal gespannt, wie das sich entwickelt. Ich glaube da weiter dran, dass der eine ganz große Karriere haben kann, aber irgendwie ist der komplett im Tief. Johannes Eggestein hat jetzt gegen den KSC zweimal getroffen, er ist jetzt mit fünf Toren der beste Torschütze, hat aber zwischendurch auch, Timo Schulz nannte das, ein körperliches Tief. Zwischen den Zeilen hat man auch lesen können, dass das körperliche Tief, dass er das auch richtig bierernst meinte sozusagen. Der hat sich jetzt hoffentlich da rausgearbeitet, leider ein bisschen später, aber zwischendurch war der nicht mal Stürmer Nummer 4, sondern wurde einfach gar nicht mehr eingewechselt. Da ist tatsächlich einiges schiefgelaufen. Jetzt so nach Ende der Hinrunde muss man das klar sagen. Also in der Offensive, da wurden die Spieler, die weggegangen sind, nicht adäquat ersetzt. Und zwar, man erwartet ja gar nicht, dass jemand wie Kofi, der in die erste Liga geht für viereinhalb Millionen, dass man da einen Ersatz findet, der sofort die gleiche Leistung bringt. Kofi hat auf jeden Fall war das der Unterschied, Spieler schon in der Rückrunde der letzten Saison, derjenige, der dafür gesorgt hat, dass St. Pauli überhaupt noch richtig gut gepunktet hat. Der war auf jeden Fall der Einzige, der diese Leistung aus der Hinterrunde halten konnte. Das erwartet man gar nicht, dass man den so direkt eins zu eins ersetzt, aber es ist halt doch schon ziemlich wenig dafür nachgekommen. Also das ist alles nicht so aufgegangen wie geplant mit Sicherheit. Es fehlen da vor allem, wenn man mal von der Torgefahr ein bisschen weggeht, es fehlen vor allem Skills, die andere Teams haben. Wir haben über Greuther Fürth gesprochen. Lange Michael, das fand ich alles total spannend. Was bei Greuther Fürth auffällig finde, ist, dass wenn man sich die Höchstgeschwindigkeiten von den Spielern anguckt, dann ist Greuther Fürth mit neun Spielern in den Top 100. Und beim FC St. Pauli ist das halt einer. Und das noch nicht mal, das ist Etienne Amenido. Und das Tempo, das fehlt dem FC St. Pauli total. Also wirklich auf ganzer Linie und was dem Team auch fehlt, ist Kopfballstärke dann in vorderster Reihe. Deswegen habe ich auch vorhin schon angedeutet, so jemand wie Terrence Boyd oder so wird dem FC St. Pauli total gut tun. Das sind einfach so zwei Skills, die man nicht im Team hat. Und das sind auch zwei Skills, die man nicht über andere Wege ersetzen kann. Das geht einfach nicht. Also Kopfballstärke und Tempo, das ist nichts, was man irgendwie ausgleichen kann durch besondere gute Kombinationen oder so. St. Pauli hat halt inzwischen lassen Teams schon Flanken zu vom FC St. Pauli so ungefähr, weil sie wissen, da ist nicht so viel zu holen. Und das ist halt schwierig. Dazu kommt dann auch noch, dass St. Pauli ähnlich wie der KSC zur Saison beginnt, jetzt inzwischen vier Innenverteidiger hat, die verletzt oder gesperrt fehlten zum Ende der Hinrunde. Und das hat man leider auch gemerkt, vor allem beim 4-4 in Karlsruhe dann. Wo wirklich, anders kann man nicht sagen, so eklatante individuelle Abwehrfehler zu jedem einzelnen Gegentor geführt haben. Und diese Stabilität, die fehlte dann auch im Spielaufbau. Das hat man auch gemerkt dann in den Spielen davor. Und ja, es läuft einfach nicht. Es ist wirklich eine ganz schwere Saison. Und ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich bin froh, ich bin richtig froh, dass diese Hinrunde vorbei ist und dass die Winterpause sehr lang ist. Emotional hat dieses ganze Jahr, 2022, mit dem verpassten Aufstieg und mit der Hinrunde jetzt. Das hat richtig, richtig Kraft gekostet.
Was ich halt bei St. Pauli irgendwie – ich hatte zwischendurch gedacht, so dieses auf links irgendwie Paccarada, beziehungsweise, also man hat irgendwie Paccarada und Sal Yacas, die eigentlich gut irgendwie die Flanken auch eingebracht haben. Aber es fehlt halt wirklich einer, der sie vorne halt reinmacht. Also ich meine, ich habe St. Pauli ja gegen Bielefeld auch gesehen. Da war es halt einfach unfassbar unglücklich, dass man in der ersten Hälfte nicht getroffen hat. Aber dass man dann halt, also dann gerade irgendwie gegen Amine Bielefeld verliert, die jetzt auch nicht dafür bekannt sind, unfassbar viele, also normalerweise unfassbar viele Tore zu schießen in den letzten drei Jahren. Das ist halt einfach dann auch nicht gut. Und was ich da halt einfach gesehen habe, das, was von der Bank da kam, das war natürlich auch viel verletzungsgeschuldet. Das haben wir ja auch mit Janik von Millantoon besprochen damals. Das war dann schon irgendwie sehr enttäuschend. Ich finde halt noch so einen Spieler, den ich eigentlich sehr interessant finde, ist eben Conor Metcalf. Der hat jetzt aber, glaube ich, das erste Mal gegen Kiel von Anfang an gespielt. Und das ist eigentlich, also da frage ich mich auch, ich fand der, wenn der reingekommen ist, natürlich kann ein so ein Spieler, auch wenn der gerade dann, ich meine, von der Australischen Liga in die zweite Liga zu kommen ist, glaube ich, halt schon noch ein relativ großer Schritt. Aber ich würde von dem halt gerne mehr von Anfang an sehen, weil ich schon einen interessanten Spieler finde. Aber ja, generell sind ja Stürmer da, aber ich glaube, da muss halt irgendwie eine Kaderveränderung rein. Was ich halt so krass fand, ist, dass Timo Schulz meinte, es gibt halt einfach irgendwie keine Entwicklung im Kader. Ich meine, das hätte er nach irgendeinem Spiel gesagt. Und ich finde, das ist halt schon, oder keine Entwicklung, auch aus Fehlern lernen. Also ich meine, so was wie mit den Abwehrfehlern. Also ich meine, ganz ehrlich, auch schon das erste Spiel gegen Nürnberg. Da waren so viele Unaufmerksamkeiten dabei. Irgendwie ein Medic, der zwar eigentlich so eine sehr, sehr hohe Passquote auch irgendwie mitbringt, wenn er spielt. Da glaube ich, der drittplatzierte der Liga ist. Aber einfach, also so viele Defensivfehler und so viel auch nicht gut verteidigt auch gegen Bielefeld. Also ich meine, dass da auch nicht mehr auf zum Beispiel jemand wie Gehbauer gespielt wurde, der halt wirklich kein guter Verteidiger ist. Und dass da irgendwie nicht drauf gespielt wurde, auch wenn man wenig Potenzial hat, da noch rein zu bringen, das fand ich schon durchaus erschreckend. Und ich hatte vor der Saison St. Pauli, glaube ich, immer auf Platz 11 getippt und musste mir da durchaus negative Kommentare zu anhören. Tim, um dir und mir mal Hoffnung zu machen, witzigerweise hatte Janik mich drauf gebracht, weil er meinte, schlechte Hinrunden kämen bei St. Pauli auch. In der Saison 2020-2021 war St. Pauli auch 15. mit 16 Punkten und ist hinterher noch 10. Bielefeld war in der Saison 2018-2019 14. mit 18 Punkten, war jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel und ist hinterher noch 7. geworden. Wir dürfen noch nicht aufgeben hier.
Nein, das sowieso nicht.
Nein, aber ist natürlich klar. Das sage ich auch immer wieder. Ich finde, diese lange Winterpause, zum Beispiel für Arminia, da reden wir ja gleich drüber, weiß ich gar nicht, ob das jetzt zum richtigen Zeitpunkt kommt oder nicht. Klar, Verstärkung hier und da, Kaderveränderung. Aber dieses erste Spiel im Januar, die ersten zwei, drei Spiele, wenn es dann wieder losgeht im neuen Jahr, da muss man, glaube ich, wichtiger als jemals aus dieser Winterpause rauskommen. Weil wir ja, wie gesagt, sehen, so ein negativ oder positives Serien, so ein Trend, kann halt durchaus sich selber Steine in den Weg legen.
Ich finde das interessant, dass du Conor Metcalf rausgepickt hast, weil das ist tatsächlich, wenn man sich den Kader des FC St. Pauli anschaut, ist das der einzige Spieler, und mit dem hat man noch gar nicht so gerechnet. Da hat man eher gedacht, der braucht mindestens ein halbes Jahr, bis er auf dieses Level 2. Liga gekommen ist, weil er aus der australischen 1. Liga kam. Das ist wirklich der einzige, der auch im Kader Druck macht auf die Startelf sozusagen. Und das ist wahrscheinlich auch eines der Probleme, die der FC St. Pauli hat. Die haben viele Spieler abgegeben, nicht jeden Spieler. Also haben weniger neue Spieler dazugeholt, als sie abgegeben haben. Und ich fürchte so ein bisschen, dass das Trainingslevel vielleicht auch ein bisschen nachgelassen hat. Und wenn du ein Level im Training nicht hast, dann wirst du es auch im Spiel nicht haben. Und dann wird es halt schwierig und dann nimmt das so eine negative Spirale an. Das aber, bevor ich jetzt der Eindruck entsteht, ich finde, dass der FC St. Pauli schlecht spielt, das finde ich tatsächlich nicht. Wenn man sich die Statistiken anguckt und viele, mit denen ich zu tun habe, rund um den FC St. Pauli, sind davon schon genervt, wenn ich mit so etwas ankomme. Weil der FC St. Pauli lässt mit Abstand die wenigsten gegnerischen Torschüsse der Liga zu, hat mit Abstand den niedrigsten gegnerischen Expected Goals Wert, hat die zweitmeisten eigenen Torschüsse abgegeben, bringt die meisten Pässe zum Mitspieler im gegnerischen Strafraum und ist das zweikampfstärkste Team der Liga. Aus den Zahlen kann ich auf gar keinen Fall herleiten, dass es sich dabei um ein Team auf Platz 15 handeln soll. Das erscheint mir eigentlich fast komplett surreal. Das ist tatsächlich auch so eine Sache, dass der FC St. Pauli auch viel Pech hatte in der Hinrunde. Manchmal hat man Gründe, warum man sich dann doch die Gegentore fängt, beziehungsweise die Tore vorne nicht macht. Das ist dann höchstwahrscheinlich auch nicht nur Pech, aber es ist eine schwierige Situation und nimmt dann wahrscheinlich auch irgendwann so eine Negativspirale an und dann irgendwann fängt man auch an, schlecht zu spielen. Aber lange Zeit hat man eben gut gespielt und sich, wie Timo Schulz, ich glaube 400 Mal während der Hinrunde gesagt hat, man hat sich nicht belohnt dafür.
Ich hätte auch noch eine Frage, jetzt die Rückfrage an Tim. Wie ist es denn beim FC St. Pauli mit dem Transfersort oder mit dem Scouting? Weil das ist dann schon auffällig. Ich habe jetzt Conor Metcalf angesprochen aus Australien. Ich habe mir gerade parallel nochmal die Transfersorte der letzten Jahre angeschaut. Da sind immer mal wieder welche dabei, die von Vereinen und aus Ligen kommen, die man jetzt nicht unbedingt im Blick hat. Also es ist ein besonders gutes Scouting. Ist es datenbasiert oder wie kommt man auf diese Spieler überhaupt? Weil es gibt ja auch Vereine der zweiten Liga, die sagen, wir holen vor allem Spieler aus dem deutschsprachigen Raum, weil man die so gut integrieren kann, was teilweise vielleicht kaschiert, dass man auch gar nicht so gut aufgestellt ist im Scouting.
Also datenbasiert ist es auf jeden Fall nicht. So viel kann ich sagen, das weiß ich. Es wird nicht speziell explizit mit vielen Daten gearbeitet, eigene Modelle erstellt und und und. Aber ja, es ist total auffällig, dass der FC St. Pauli Spieler aus Ligen holt, die irgendwie ja ein bisschen schon exotisch sind. Conor Metcalf zum Beispiel, Jackson Irvine, australischer Nationalspieler, fällt jetzt zur WM. Der wird aus England geholt auf einen Spielertyp, bei dem man überhaupt nicht ansieht, dass das ein Fußballer ist oder dass der überhaupt der physisch stärkste Mittelfeldspieler der 2. Liga ist. So sieht er halt überhaupt nicht aus. Afiz Aremu, der jetzt auf der 6 endlich nach 2 Jahren durchstartet und die letzten 4-5 Spiele richtig, richtig stark gespielt hat, der ist aus Norwegen gekommen, der hat im Grunde 2 Jahre lang echt Anpassungsprobleme gehabt und wird jetzt auf jeden Fall doch noch einiges bringen können. In Sachen Scouting bin ich mir nicht so sicher, inwiefern da auch einfach über das Adressbuch gearbeitet wird. Und über die Berater-Agenturen. Also ich würde mal vorsichtig die These in den Raum stellen, dass der FC St. Pauli nicht explizit in der australischen Liga scoutet. Also dass es solche Transfers gibt, die passieren dann wahrscheinlich eher über Kontakte. Rodrigo Salazar ist auch ein gutes Beispiel. Er ist ja aus der polnischen vierten Liga gekommen, weil er ja ein Leihgeschäft war bei Frankfurt, wurde dann verliehen nach Polen und ist da dann aus der ersten Mannschaft in die zweite Mannschaft gegangen, weil er selber unbedingt spielen wollte und in der ersten Mannschaft nicht zum Zug gekommen ist. Und das war auch schon so eine – Ja, Timo Schulz hat das mal als Wunderkerze bezeichnet. Es gibt so Transfers, die sind so – Da meinte er, da kann man sich ein bis zwei pro Saison erlauben. So Wunderkerzen, die können komplett funktionieren oder kann halt komplett in die Hose gehen. Und wenn sie halt funktionieren, so wie im Fall Salazar oder jetzt hoffentlich Aremu, dann ist das natürlich super. Aber es gibt auch viele Beispiele, wo das eben nicht funktioniert.
Na, dann bin ich ja mal gespannt, welche Wunderkerzen wir jetzt in Bielefeld anzünden dürfen. Sie sind das nächste Team, über das wir sprechen wollen. Ebenfalls 17 Punkte. Dabei hat man sechs dieser 17 Punkte aus den letzten zwei Spielen gehört. Also englische Wochen, auch wenn sie schwierig sind, die Spiele auseinanderzuhalten. Eva, das lief jetzt mal erfolgreich. In Paderborn mit 2 zu 0 gewonnen und jetzt zu Hause gegen Magdeburg, über die wir dann gleich auch noch sprechen wollen, mit 3 zu 1. Wie ist denn jetzt die Lage der Nation in Bielefeld?
Ja, also ich glaube, es war mal wichtig, das erste Mal zwei Spiele in Folge zu gewinnen in dieser Saison. Ein Auswärtsspiel seit Januar mal wieder zu gewinnen. Immer noch finde ich es sehr amüsant, dass davor der letzte Auswärtssieg beim späteren Europa-League-Sieger war. Auch das Bielefeld-Dings so. Also bei Eintracht Frankfurt. Sehr andere Zeit irgendwie noch. Wenn ich mal zurückdenke gleichzeitig, glaube ich, dass man das Bielefeld ganz gut einschätzen kann. Also hoffe ich auf jeden Fall. Die Fans können es auf jeden Fall ganz gut einschätzen, indem sie eben auch sagen, gut vor einem Jahr dachten wir auch irgendwie mal, nach zwei Siegen in Folge, jetzt ist der Abstieg ganz weit weg und jetzt sind wir gerettet. Ja, reden jetzt hier über die 2. Liga. Es ist Beweis genug, dass das nicht so wahnsinnig toll geklappt hat. Ich glaube, die Frage ist bei mir immer noch so ein bisschen, hat Daniel Scherning jetzt den Turnaround geschafft? Ich bin dabei nach 50-50 Antwort, weil es mir z.T. in zu vielen Spielen immer noch zu viele Fragezeichen sind, dass ich Einwechslung auch nicht verstehe. Also ich bin wie gesagt kein wahnsinnig großer Fan von auf einzelne Spieler draufhauen. Aber ich bin schon immer wieder entsetzt, wie wenn man Yanni Serra rausnimmt und Brian Lassme bringt, was für ein absoluter spielerischer Abfall – also nicht die Person, sondern Abfall im Spielsystem, um Himmel zu wählen – dann auf dem Platz passiert, weil Yanni Serra, auch wenn er nicht die meisten Tore schießt, aber zumindest körperlich sich gut im Ball stellen kann, gut in Zweikämpfe gehen kann und Lassme leider immer aussieht, als wolle er den Ball auch gar nicht haben, ist als Stürmer immer ein bisschen schlecht. Und da sind immer noch zu viele Fragezeichen. Was ich finde, was sehr wichtig war, ist, dass man gegen Magdeburg gewonnen hat. Erstens, weil es halt ein Mitkandidat ist und man Magdeburg hinter sich lassen konnte. Und auch, weil man drei sehr wichtige Ausfälle in diesem Spiel hatte. Wie gegen Paderborn sind Sebastian Vassayades und Ivan Levinice. Lucas Klünter ist warum auch immer vom Platz geflogen. Er war glaube ich der fünfte Platzverweis von Bielefeld in dieser Saison. Ich glaube, so viele hat kein anderer Verein in der 2. Liga. Und dann stand da eben im Zentrum Manuel Pritl, der seit seiner Corona-Infektion letztes Jahr im Winter einfach nicht mehr der Gleiche ist, der eigentlich Nummer 2 hinter Lepiniza ist, zum Teil auch überhaupt nicht spielt. Er hat dann eher Kronbrunnen, Vasejanes oder so gespielt. Und Lepiniza hat einfach die höchste Passquote aller Bielefelder. Und dadurch halt einfach sehr, sehr wichtig ist im Zentrum. Ich sowieso finde, dass er einer der Top-Transfers ist, wenn man da irgendwie als Tabellensechzehntner von sprechen kann. Also er ist definitiv eine sehr, sehr wichtige Ergänzung im Zentrum. Ich gucke ihm tatsächlich auch sehr gerne beim Fußballspielen zu. Irgendwie finde ich, hat er für sein Alter eine ganz schöne Abgeklärtheit am Ball. Und dann eben – ich habe es eben schon mal gesagt, Christian Gebauer, ich möchte ihm nicht zu nahe treten, aber er ist halt nun mal einfach kein Verteidiger. Man sieht es einfach, dass Magdeburg auch viele Chancen hat, einfach weil sie seine Seite gut bespielt haben und er immer wieder gedoppelt wurde und da einfach nicht gegen anlaufen konnte, im Gegensatz zu einem Lukas Klinter, der vielleicht am Ball nicht der Beste ist, aber einfach eine gewisse Schnelligkeit mitbringt. Und ja, gut, dann hatte man Kronzburg, der ja tatsächlich als Bielefelder Jungen sein erstes Tor gemacht hat am Wochenende. Aber ich sage mal so, das Problem ist halt einfach, dass diese Winterpause kann für Bielefeld alles noch schlimmer machen, weil es im Raum steht, dass Robin Huck und Masaya Okugawa verkauft werden sollen. Zur Einordnung, Robin Huck hat die meisten Tore war Aminia geschossen bis jetzt mit 8. Masaya Okugawa hat 6 Torverlagen und ist damit, teilt sich mit Jan-Niklas Beste den zweiten Platz von allen, die bis jetzt da Assist gegeben haben. Das wäre natürlich extrem bitter, weil ich glaube, wir brauchen nicht lange darüber diskutieren, kreativ sind das die wichtigsten Spieler, die Aminia in diesem Kader hat. Und ohne das möchte ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen, wie die Spiele laufen. Man hat genug in genug Spielen gesehen, wie das laufen kann, wenn eben dieser Kreativposten weggenommen wird. Man sieht halt auch ganz klar, dass einem, also wo man vielleicht vor Beginn der Saison gesagt hat, es fehlt ein Stürmer hinter Klos, jetzt würde ich sagen, es fehlt ganz klar ein Stürmer hinter Janis Serra, weil Fabian Klos es ist nicht. Gut, der war auch viel verletzt, aber der strahlt halt lange nicht mehr das aus, was er mal ausgestrahlt hat. Zu langsam kennen die Zweitliga-Innverteidiger ihn mehr oder weniger, selbst wenn sie noch nie vorher gegen ihn gespielt haben, aber kennen Fabian Klos halt irgendwie. Und wenn man es dann von der Größe, von der Statue auch mit einem Kleindienst vergleicht, bringt er das halt nicht mit. Und das ist halt durchaus ein Problem. Gerade was offensiv zum Teil Wechsel betrifft, aber eben auch die Außenverteidigerposition. Ich bin sehr froh, dass Baseljano Cipka sich nicht nochmal verletzt hat. Der ist unfassbar wichtig im Zentrum, in der Innenverteidigung. Finde ich, hat man jetzt mit Hüsing, Andrade und Ramos schon so wenigstens gleichwertig gefunden. Die letzten beiden Spiele waren eben mit Andrade und Ramos. Gerade Ramos, der das zum Teil sehr unkonventionell verteidigt und zum Teil auch sehr, sehr riskant, wo dann auch einfach sehr ungenaue Pässe oder Klärungsversuche in den Beinen des Gegners landen und das dann zu schnellen Umschaltmomenten des Gegners führt. Natürlich hatte der Trainer wechselnden Effekt. Man hat, glaube ich, bis auf das Spiel gegen Kaiserslautern und gegen Karlsruhe, sonst hat man alle Heimspiele gewonnen unter Scherning, also Braunschweig, Kiel, St. Pauli und Magdeburg. Man hat auch alle Siege unter Scherning geholt. Aber gerade auswärts war das sehr oft viel zu wenig. Auch so die Spiele gegen Nürnberg, Kaiserslautern gegen Fürth, die darfst du so niemals verlieren. Ich glaube, da ist dann im Endeffekt die Frage, was passiert denn im Winter? Da ist gerade offensiv das große Fragezeichen, sollten Okugawa und Hack gehen? Diese Mannschaft hat so lange gebraucht, sich einzufinden und da zwei neue Spieler reinzuhauen, die niemals, niemals, statt jetzt so schnell die spielerischen Qualitäten von den beiden ersetzen können. Das ist ein bisschen eklig.
Aber warum steht denn das im Raum, dass die gehen? Also wollen die weg, haben die ganz tolle Angebote und könnten sich dann gehaltstechnisch und vielleicht auch sportlich verbessern? Oder ist es eine finanzielle Notwendigkeit, in der Bielefeld da drin steckt? Das scheint ja so ein bisschen kontraintuitiv zu sein.
Ja, ich glaube, es ist so ein bisschen beides. Also ich glaube, durchaus finanziell ist halt – ich weiß nicht, ob man sich da mit im Notfall schon mal absichern will, sollte es doch in die 3. Liga gehen, was halt irgendwie ein bisschen ironisch wäre, weil ohne die – also sag ich jetzt einfach mal so plump, aber ist so ein Drittliga-Abstieg, glaube ich, nochmal – oder ein Abstieg in die 3. Liga nochmal um einiges wahrscheinlicher. Es ist natürlich jetzt viel Spekulation. Ich meine, es war schon mal die Diskussion, ob Hack im Sommer nicht weggeht. Ich glaube, das war auch nach dem Spiel gegen Heidenheim die Frage, ob er noch quasi mit den letzten Zügen des Transferfensters wechselt. Ich sag mal so, also bei Okugawa könnte ich – er hatte, glaube ich, auch so die größten Anpassungsschwierigkeiten in der 2. Liga. Von allen Spielern hatte ich so das Gefühl, dass er ja erstmal damit klarkommen musste, dass es um einiges physischer auch zugeht. Damit hat er große Probleme, weil ich zum Beispiel die Vorlage zum Tor von Gehbauer am Wochenende gegen Magdeburg – das war so ein bisschen der Okugawa, den man vielleicht auch in der Bundesliga sehen konnte. Ich glaube, er weiß halt auch irgendwie, dass er dadurch, dass er jetzt halt 2. Liga Fußball spielt, eben aus dem Kader von Japan jetzt bei der WM keine Rolle gespielt hat. Würde ich jetzt mal irgendwie spekulieren, sage ich mal so, dass er vielleicht da auch irgendwie sich besser sieht. Ich sag mal so, ich würde da jetzt erstmal vorsichtig gucken, was passiert. Genau sagen kann ich es nicht, weil finanziell hat Aminia noch nie wahr, sie sind nicht gut dargestanden. Sie stehen schon besser da, also man hat, glaube ich, wieder positives Eigenkapital, positives Eigenkapital erwirtschaften können. Aber ja, also es ist wahrscheinlich haben sowohl ein Okugawa als auch ein Huxix anders vorgestellt, als jetzt irgendwie froh darüber sein zu müssen, dass man doch noch 16. ist vor der Winterpause statt 18.
Jetzt haben wir ja das letzte Mal miteinander gesprochen nach dem fünften Spieltag, da hatte Bielefeld noch nicht gewonnen und da gab es damals schon, hast du glaube ich auch gesagt, dass die Panik durchaus größer ist als den Fürth zum Beispiel, da lief es ja bei denen am Anfang auch nicht so. Und in der Vergangenheit hast du vor allem in der ersten Liga noch oft gesagt, in Samir Weetrust, also Samir Arabi, das ist derjenige, der hat dann schon immer eine Idee, wie man eben mit klugen Transfers Bielefeld dann irgendwie sportlich verstärken kann. Dann hast du mir damals in diesem Kurzpass schon gesagt, er sieht nicht mehr so souverän aus wie in der Vergangenheit. Wie ist denn jetzt seine Rolle aktuell bei Bielefeld? Weil er ist ja maßgeblich derjenige, der zusammen mit dem Trainer das dann sportlich in bessere Bahnen lenkt muss.
Ja, es ist ja ein bisschen ironisch, dass man jetzt zwei Siege in Folge geholt hat, als er mehr Ravi-Innen-Raum-Verbot hatte, weil er nicht ganz so nette Worte für den Schiedsrichter gegen Kaiserslautern übrig hatte. Das Problem ist natürlich, dass wenn man sieht, was ein Trainerwechsel für einen Effekt haben kann, wie er bei Führer ist, ist natürlich immer so ein bisschen die Frage, warum ist damals dann die Wahl auf Daniel Scherning gefallen? Klar, es gab einen Tod.
Warum nicht Alex Zorniger?
Nein, aber er stand ja wie ungefähr Halbfußballdeutscher natürlich auch irgendwie im Raum, als möglicher Kandidat. Das Problem ist natürlich, und das habe ich schon mal gesagt, dass natürlich die Menge an Trainern, die Bielefeld dann in den letzten Jahren durchgegangen ist, schon relativ hoch war und das schon auch länger so war. Und dass natürlich dann irgendwann, wenn ein Sportgeschäftsführer elf Jahre, zwölf Jahre bei einem Verein ist – elf Jahre sind es – durchaus dann irgendwann mal dann vorsichtig auch in die Richtung guckt. Er hat sich jetzt zuletzt auch relativ viel aus öffentlichen Gesprächen rausgehalten. Unter dem Vorwand, man wäre halt eben schon auf Vorbereitung auf der Winterpause nicht verfügbar. Ich glaube auch, dass Sami Yarabi weiß, dass wenn Daniel Scherning eben nicht diese zwei Siege noch geholt hätte. Also ich meine, es gab durchaus dann Diskussionen nach dem Fürth Spiel. Ist Daniel Scherning der richtige Kandidat? Und ich glaube schon, dass auch intern dann der Druck auf Arabi so groß gewesen wäre, wo man nicht sicher gewesen wäre, okay, wenn Scherning geht, ist es dann jetzt quasi auch Zeit für Sami Yarabi. Ich meine, wir hatten halt schon mal diese Saison, wo man drei Trainer in einer Saison hatte, wo es auch zwei komplette Fehlgriffe gab mit Rüdiger Rehm und Jürgen Kramny und dann holte man eben Jeff Zaybene. Aber auch das hat dann ja nicht wahnsinnig lange gehalten. Dann kam Uwe Neuhaus. Das hat dann bis Ende der Bundesligasaison gehalten. Frank Cramer. Okay, haben wir, glaube ich, genug darüber geredet. Brauche ich auch nicht mehr drüber reden, aber es ist natürlich – und dann eben Uli Forte, der halt wirklich laut Markus Reheck, ehemaliger Finanzgeschäftsführer, ein kompletter Fehlgriff war, ein Missverständnis. Ja, das Problem ist halt, wir haben – intern gibt es eben auch eine neue Strukturierung. Christopher Wortmann ist jetzt neuer Finanzgeschäftsführer. Von ihm hat man irgendwie jetzt auch gar nichts Öffentlich-Wirksames gehört. Also ich weiß noch nicht mal, wie der Kerl aussieht so richtig. Aber ja, also ich weiß es halt nicht, ne. Also klar ist, dass Amina sich einen Abstieg nicht leisten kann. Das ist eigentlich – also man muss einfach mal sagen, wir hatten in den letzten drei Heimspielen trotzdem einen Zuschauer in einem Schnitt von, glaube ich, 22.000. Ich finde, das ist nicht selbstverständlich nach den beiden Saisons. Man ist, glaube ich, auf Platz 8 dieser Durchschnittstabelle, die Michi ja auch mit Heidenheim, glaube ich, eben einmal angesprochen hatte. Aber klar ist halt auch, dass man jetzt in dieser Winterpause sehr, sehr viel verbessern muss und dass man, ja, lange Bälle einfach, glaube ich, erstmal so ein bisschen in Richtung, dass es dann im Notfall ein Plan B und definitiv kein Plan A ist. Und dass, ja, ich glaube, auch Fans und Vereine, die verstehen müssen, dass Fabian Klose wirklich auch nur noch, ja, die Nummer 2 ist. Und ich habe das schon mal gesagt, ich habe mich noch nie in meinem Leben so geschämt wie gegen St. Pauli, als dann bei der Aufstellung, also als die Aufstellung angesagt wurde und man kam auf die Ersatzbank und dann mit der Name von Yannis Herra ausgerufen, dass dann gefiffen wurde, genauso wie als er dann eingeweskelt wurde für Klose. Ich meine, er hat dann halt zwei Tore gemacht, dann war alles okay. Aber ich habe das schon mal gesagt, ich verstehe diese absolute Abneigung gegen Yannis Herra nicht. Also wenn der zwei Tore in Folge schießt, oder in einem Spiel sagt, ja, da muss er jetzt erst mal beweisen, was er kann. Wenn Robin Hack zwei Tore in zwei Spielen schießt, wird gesagt, ja, hier, bester Mann, bester Transfer, er war, ja, super. Also kann ich halt nicht nachvollziehen, finde ich halt ein bisschen schwierig. Und ja, gerade auch weil Sarah und Kloswu sich sehr, sehr gut privat verstehen, ist das irgendwie eine merkwürdige Geschichte, wo das Bielefelder Publikum sich, glaube ich, auch selber mal hinterfragen muss.
Viele, viele Themen. Ich habe gehört, dass zwischendurch Michi sich entmuted hatte. Dann war ich aber schon reingegretscht. Mitten in meiner Gretsche war ich da schon fliegend. Also so früher wie Lucio, wenn er auch schon gewusst hat, oh, war keine gute Idee, aber jetzt bin ich schon unterwegs. Michi, jetzt darfst du aber.
Ich habe mich auch nur kurz entmuted, weil ich aus der Zwischengrätsche wollte beim Finanziellen. Wie Eva jetzt angesprochen hatte, die beiden Spieler müssen, sollen, könnten verkauft werden. Wie steht es denn da? Also vielleicht in aller Kürze nur mit Blick auf die Uhr, aber wie steht es denn um die Arminia? Wir haben ja in der Bundesliga-Saison mal länger über Arminia gesprochen, Eva, über das Bündnis Ostwestfalen, über die knapp abgewendete Insolvenz. Aber man war jetzt ja in der Bundesliga. Wenn ich so den Vergleich ziehe, Fürth, hieß es immer, man hat sich durch den Bundesliga-Aufstieg für all die Verluste in der Corona-Zeit rehabilitiert, hat das negative Eigenkapital fast wieder auf Vor-Corona-Niveau gehoben. Also die Bilanzpressekonferenz ist jetzt in dieser Woche nach hinrunden Ende. Aber wie steht es denn da um die Arminia?
Ja, ich wäre dieser Aufnahme jetzt eine Woche später, könnte ich dir da auch mehr zu sagen, weil wir nächste Woche Montag eine Jahres-Hauptversammlung haben. Und ja, meistens dann so ist, also generell glaube ich, ist dem Ganzen geschuldet, dass es jetzt auch einen Wechsel im Finanziellen gab. Markus Reak hat eben zum Abschied eben gesagt, Bielefeld hat jetzt wieder ein positives Eigenkapital. Also so schlimm ist es finanziell nicht, wie man vielleicht denken könnte. Ich glaube, da war einfach, dass man es halt ein Jahr in der Bundesliga ausgehalten hat, sage ich mal so. Dass man halt einmal den Klassenerhalt geschafft hat, war schon durchaus wichtig. Man hat halt irgendwie noch mit Demi Dina auch nochmal und ich glaube, oh Gott, also Funderhorn, glaube ich auch am Beginn der Saison, könnte man noch ein paar Transfer-Erlöser erziehen, jetzt nicht wahnsinnig hoch und glaube auch definitiv nicht aufwiegend mit dem, was man auch irgendwie für einen Bello oder für einen Inchel ausgegeben hat. Also das muss man ja eh dazu sagen, es werden ja kaum noch Vertragslaufzeiten kommuniziert, noch werden Ablösesumme wirklich kommuniziert, von Bielefeld sowieso nicht. Also man weiß bei der Hälfte der Spieler gar nicht, wie lange sie unterschrieben hat. Ich glaube, das war aber auch irgendwie eine Empfehlung der DFL im Sommer. Ich weiß es nicht mehr so genau, ich hätte da mal sowas gesehen. Das heißt, ich weiß es, also ich würde gerne mehr dazu sagen, aber ich glaube einfach auch, weil es jetzt diesen Wechsel in der Position gab, wird es halt nächste Woche dann mit Wortmann und der JHV das erste Mal da wirklich nochmal klare Zahlen geben. Wie gesagt, das sieht nicht ganz so dunkel aus, wie vielleicht noch vor drei, vier Jahren. Gut, noch dunkler ging es halt auch fast nicht. Aber ja, also klar ist, und das hat Markus Reheck eben auch so gesagt, ein Drittliga-Ausstieg ist halt für Vereine wie Namina Bielefeld. Ich meine, das hat ja auch einen Kaiserslautern gezeigt, das hat einen Braunschrank gezeigt. Das ist finanziell immer eine ganz, ganz große Katastrophe.
Ja, aber schon erstaunlich, also das Eigenkapital, das letzte von der DFL veröffentlichte Eigenkapital ist das aus der Saison 2021. Da waren das minus 7 Millionen, das heißt, allein die hat man wieder reingeholt. Sicherlich hat auch Patrick Wimmer da noch eine Rolle gespielt, der hat ja auch noch Transfererlöse eingespielt. Also dann gucken wir auf die… Ja, ja, genau. Ich musste ein bisschen schmunzeln, als du über den so drüber hinweggegangen bist. Gut, aber das hat dann vielleicht andere Gründe. Wir beobachten das bei der Armenia und wir schauen jetzt auch nochmal auf den 1. FC Magdeburg, den 3. Aufsteiger, der eben punktgleich – ich wiederhole mich – sehr gerne auf Platz 17 legt. Tim, du durftest jetzt lange nichts mehr sagen, deswegen hast du die Ehre einzusteigen. Was macht denn Magdeburg aus? Wir haben eigentlich vorhin schon darüber gesprochen. Kein typischer Aufsteiger, vor allem vom Spielstil her. Und jetzt aber doch zumindest stand jetzt der erfolgloseste dieser drei, wenn auch natürlich knapp mit Braunschweig. Was macht denn Magdeburg aus?
Also Magdeburg zeichnet einen sehr ballbesitzorientierten Fußball aus. Das ist ja ein fast schon klassischer Christian-Titz-Fußball, der da gespielt wird. Damit sind sie aufgestiegen. Die haben die dritte Liga in der Vor-Saison unfassbar dominiert, also haben da echt auch ganz tolle Spiele geliefert, ganz lange Zeit und haben im Grunde da angeknüpft zu Saisonbeginn, wollten genauso weiterspielen und sind damit ja nicht erwartbar, aber sind damit dann doch schon auch ein bisschen baden gegangen. Das dürfte auch daran gelegen haben, dass sie eben vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr so das Team hatten darunter rum barischartig, der in der Vorsaison 40 Scorer-Punkte oder so hatte, so eine irrwitzige Zahl, der hatte mit Verletzungsproblemen zu kämpfen zu Saisonbeginn. Dann sind drei Säulen da im Spiel, die sind durchaus gewechselt einfach, die sind alle mal im Trio rüber zu Paderborn, zu Lord Conte, Tobias Müller als Kapitän und Innenverteidiger und Raphael Obermeier, der bei Paderborn tatsächlich eine ganz andere Rolle spielt als bei Magdeburg. Da hat er auch ab und an mal als rechter Verteidiger gespielt. Jetzt bei Paderborn spielt er linksoffensiv relativ häufig, aber die drei sind weggegangen. Und im Gegensatz zu Kaiserslautern, die sich ja Weltmeister Erik Durm – ich hebe immer das Weltmeister gerne bei ihm heraus – Erik Durm geholt haben, Andreas Lute und Philipp Klemen, sehr erfahrene Leute. Und auch Braunschweig, die sich Uccia geholt haben, Demet Dina, der zwei Jahre Bundesliga gespielt hat, Endo von Union oder Benkovic, international erfahrene Spieler, hat Magdeburg das nicht so richtig gemacht. Die haben niemanden geholt, bei dem man jetzt sagen kann, der hat mehrere Jahre Zweitliganiveau gehabt, Katschuka Lua hat bei Aue in der zweiten Liga gespielt. Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man sagt, das ist jemand, der auf jeden Fall diese Mannschaft tragen kann von Anfang an. Und das hat sich dann so ein bisschen gezeigt. Magdeburg hat schon eine ganze Menge Lehrgeld am Anfang gezahlt für seinen Spielstil. Das war aber auch so zu erwarten, dass sie so spielen. Und dann hat Titz ja schon so ein bisschen umgestellt. Das muss man ja schon fast zu sagen, dass sie dann ja doch fast ein bisschen vorsichtiger geworden sind, ein bisschen abgerückt sind von dieser krassen Orientierung am Ballbesitz, weil sie eben Probleme hatten, da in den Strafraum zu kommen, der Gegner. Da gibt es einen schönen Twitter-Account, den ich sehr gerne folge. Das ist VirtualFootball Magdeburg, also add vir-football-de. Da wird Magdeburg taktisch immer ganz gut auseinandergenommen und auch zu jedem Spiel vor und nach den Spielen ganz gut das dargestellt. Und da wurde mal gezeigt, wie sich das Spiel von Magdeburg auch verändert hat im Vergleich zur Vorsaison, aber auch während der jetzigen Hinrunde. Und da kommt man eben ganz gut sehen, dass Magdeburg enorme Probleme hat, in den gegnerischen Strafraum zu kommen, obwohl sie so viel Beibesitz haben und dass diese enormen Probleme eventuell mit dem Spieltempo selber zusammenhängen. Also wenn man sich da die Pässe pro Spieltempo an sich anschaut, dann ist das im Liga-Vergleich und auch im Vergleich zur Vorsaison hat das deutlich abgenommen. Und was dann eben noch viel deutlicher abgenommen haben, ist die Erfolgsquote, wie oft sie in den Strafraum gekommen sind, auch im Vergleich zu Teams wie Kiel, Paderborn, St. Pauli. Also da hat das Team Probleme und dieser Fußball, dieser ballbesitzorientierte Fußball, der war ja, wie gesagt, war erwartbar, dass das nicht ganz so in der 2. Liga funktionieren würde, so krass, wie das in der 3. Liga funktioniert hat, hat aber dann, wenn man ganz ehrlich ist, doch noch ein bisschen eine gute Ecke schlechter funktioniert, als es mit Sicherheit ursprünglich geplant war von Magdeburg.
Ich musste gerade kurz schmunzeln, als Tim gesagt hat, man hat keine so erfahrenen Spieler geholt und man hat ja sehr, sehr spät doch noch darauf reagiert. Also Cristiano Piccini, der war ja vereinslos, den hat man geholt und der hat in diesen einigen Spielen schon gezeigt, dass er mal, wie man im Amateurfußball sagen würde, höher gespielt hat. Er hat unter anderem drei Nationalspiele für Italien und hat auch schon bei seine Vita, wenn man das mal durchliest, ist dann schon sehr, sehr spannend. Aber man hat diesen Spielertypen geholt und hat zwei zu eins in Nürnberg, glaube ich, beide Tore gemacht. Er hat zumindest getroffen dort, hat auch gegen Fürth, fand ich, ein sehr gutes Spiel gemacht. Man hat auch Herbert Bockhorn geholt, der ja auch vereinslos war, warum auch immer, der davor auch einige gute Spiele in Buchung gemacht hat. Man hat darauf reagiert, aber diese Unerfahrenheit hat man zu Beginn vor allem gemerkt und ich bin gespannt. Eigentlich ist es ja sehr, sehr schön, dass ein Aufsteiger so einen Fußball spielt. Wenn man es auch anschaut, also beibesitzt dritter Platz im Zweitliga-Vergleich. Nur ein Prozentpunkt weniger als der HSV und Paderborn. Nämlich 58 Prozent hat Magdeburg und dann noch die drittbeste Passquote mit 84 Prozent. Das liest sich alles sehr, sehr schön. Tim hat letztes Mal mit dem Kollegen Fadil Keblavi geruntet über die 2. Bundesliga, aber ich fände es extrem schade, wenn dann so ein mutiger und schön anzusehender Ansatz am Ende dann dazu führt, dass man absteigt und halt andere Vereine, die einen sehr destruktiven Ansatz haben, dann doch drinbleiben, weil sie die Zweitligatugenden besser beherrschen. Das wäre sehr, sehr traurig so aus fußballromantischer, fußballliebhaber Sicht.
Ja, das stimmt. Da stimme ich dir auf jeden Fall zu. Also es ist tatsächlich so, dass dieser ballbesitzorientierte Fußball, auch wenn man sagen muss, die erfolgreiche Passquote, die kommt vielleicht auch dadurch zustande, dass – ich weiß gar nicht, ob Riemann, der Torwart von Magdeburg – da würde ich jetzt mal die These wagen, ohne es gesehen zu haben, dass er die… Reimann. Da gibt es ja noch einen anderen, der so gut mit dem Ball am Fuß ist, aber der spielt ja in der Liga höher. Dass der die meisten Ballkontakte bei Magdeburg hat, wäre jetzt meine These. Der ist ja schon ganz stark ins Spiel eingebunden. Aber ja, es stimmt total, da so eine Ballbesitzidee, die Titz hat, und dass er die auch jetzt doch schon so ein bisschen abgewandelt hat, ein bisschen vorsichtiger agiert in den letzten Spielen, aber eben doch immer noch diese Grundidee weiterverfolgt, das ist auf jeden Fall viel schöner. Und die Spiele von Magdeburg, die sind auch einfach richtig schön anzusehen und sie haben halt auch tatsächlich Spiele drin, wo das ja eben voll aufgeht, zumindest teilweise, wenn ich an den Saisonbeginn denke, wo sie in Karlsruhe gewonnen haben, da haben sie so eine unfassbar starke erste Halbzeit gespielt. Das war richtig toll, habe ich total gern gesehen. Beim HSV haben sie auch gewonnen, das allerdings nicht unbedingt, weil sie so erfolgreich bei Ballbesitz gewesen sind, sondern auch weil der HSV ja auch einiges vergeben hat. Aber man kann durchaus sagen, 4-4 gegen Kaiserslautern war auch mittendrin. Das ist auf jeden Fall sehr attraktiv, was sie spielen. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich sage, Markteburg spielt, da schaue ich auf gar keinen Fall rein.
Was ich bei Markteburg ein bisschen interessant finde, gerade weil man sagt, es ist schade, wenn so eine Spielweise zum Abstieg führt, das erinnert mich ein bisschen als Paderborn, den der Bundesliga noch unter Baumgart gespielt hat, wo man eigentlich gesagt hat, Paderborn-Spiele waren eigentlich immer interessant anzugucken, weil sie durchaus was angeboten haben und eine relativ erfrischende Spielweise für den Aussteiger hatten. Es sind immer viele Tore gefallen, aber das Problem, so wie Paderborn es in der Bundesliga gehabt hat, hat Markteburg jetzt in der 2. Liga, das bringt alles nichts, wenn man einfach sieht, dass defensiv viel zu viele Fehler passieren. Ich meine, ich habe es jetzt gerade am Wochenende gesehen, da sind so einfache Fehler dabei, dass dieser Fehler zum 1-0 im Endeffekt, so etwas ähnliches ist dem halt zwei Wochen davor gegen Nürnberg passiert. Also ich meine, das Spiel hat man noch gewonnen, ich meine, es wäre das Spiel gewesen, wo es eben im Endeffekt dieses Eigentor ist, wo Nürnberg trotzdem kein eigenes Tor geschossen hat. Ich glaube, Müller, das irgendwie ins eigene Tor an Reimann vorbei, es passiert einfach so. Und so etwas ähnliches ist jetzt eben auch gegen Bielefeld passiert. Einfach ein viel zu ungenauer Pass zurück zum Torhüter, den dann Kuhnsbruch irgendwie unterbinden kann. Und ich glaube, das ist halt so das große Problem, dass wenn du eigentlich so viel Ballbesitz hast und eigentlich so eine hohe Passquote, dass man eigentlich automatisch davon ausgeht, dass solche Fehler da nicht passieren und sie aber leider trotzdem passieren. Und ich glaube, auch einfach das ganz grosses Problem, dass denen einfach ein klassischer Stürmer vorne noch drin fehlt, den man halt auch bei Standards – also ich meine, ich habe schon viele schlechte Ecken auch gerade von Aminia gesehen, aber also was, ich glaube Magdeburg hatte über 13 Ecken gegen Bielefeld, keine davon waren gefährlich, keine. Die haben ihr Tor durch einen schönen Umschaltmoment dann hinterher auch mit Ito geschossen, aber gerade eckballtechnisch sind die auf Platz 18 der Liga und das hat halt auch was damit zu tun, dass wahrscheinlich im Prinzip auf so ein klassischer Stürmer vielleicht auch fehlt. Klar, Puccini hat die Rolle schon einmal eingenommen, dann eben als Abwehrspieler, aber manchmal brauchst du das eben als Aussteiger, dass du sagst, okay, wenn sonst halt nicht viel kommt, komme ich halt eben über die Standards. Aber dafür, ich meine, wenn ich mir schon 14 oder 13 Ecken in einem Spiel erarbeite und ich sehe, okay, der Gegner macht irgendwie aus drei Chancen drei Tore, so nach dem Motto, da muss halt irgendwie mehr kommen.
Ja, das ist halt wirklich das, was heraussticht bei Magdeburg, die schlechte Abwehr. Und ich konnte jetzt leider die Ballkontakte nicht recherchieren, aber tatsächlich bei den Pässen ist es so, es spielt nur Silas Knacker noch mehr Pässe pro Spiel, die ankommen als eben Dominik Reimann. Aber wenn man die Gesamtpässe, also diejenigen, die auch nicht ankommen, zusammenzählt, Dominik Reimann ist der mit den meisten Pässen. Und das kennt man ja von Tizmannschaften, da wird ja interessant aufgebaut und es ist ja auch schön, dass es ein anderer Ansatz ist. Aber ich finde, ihr habt ganz gut die Problemfelder da beschrieben und da müssen wir dann vielleicht auch mal in einem zukünftigen Kurzpass noch mal genauer draufgucken. Jetzt haben wir nur noch ein Team, über das wir sprechen wollen und das liegt auch nur ein Pünktchen hinter Magdeburg. Auch wenn grundsätzlich der Saisonverlauf dieser Hinrunde für den SV Sandhausen alles andere als angenehm war. Das ist im Grunde so ein bisschen, wie man sich eine Skisprungsstanze vorstellt, wenn man sich einfach nur den Platzierungsverlauf anguckt. Es ging nämlich immer weiter nach unten. Es begann auf dem 6. Tabellenplatz am 1. Spieltag und jetzt sprechen wir eben am 17. Spieltag auch tatsächlich über Tabellenplatz 18, die schlechteste Platzierung am Ende der Hinrunde. Michael, was ist da bei Sandhausen? Das ist ja immer das Symbol für die 2. Liga. Es ist auch ein bisschen das Symbol der 2. Liga, weil es früher oft bedeutete 1 zu 0, 0 zu 1 oder 1 zu 1. Was hätten sie denn gern? Ach so, 0 zu 0 hätten wir auch noch im Angebot. Jetzt gucke ich die letzten zwei Spiele an. 3 zu 4 gegen Heidenheim verloren, 2 zu 4 gegen den HSV. Also zumindest da hat sich ein bisschen was getan. Könnte aber auch jetzt irgendwie nur Recency-Bias bei mir sein.
Man sieht an den beiden Ergebnissen, die du gerade genannt hast, schon, dass Sandhausen ein bisschen an spielerische Qualitäten gewonnen hat. Also die beiden Kindzombie-Brüder, wenn sie dann zusammen spielen, das ist schon nicht mehr so normales Sandhausen-Fußball, wie man ihn in den letzten Jahren immer wieder erlebt hat. Aber ich muss auch sagen, im Zweite-Liga-Vergleich von den 17 Teams, war sie auch einfach eines der schlechtesten und eines der bietesten. In Fürth hätten sie auch keinen Punkt geholt, wenn sie nicht dazu eingeladen worden wären. Das war Max Christianzen, der einfach den Ball so am Gegenspiel überlassen hat, so 20 Meter vom eigenen Tor. Aber insgesamt, auch wenn man ein bisschen auf die oberflächlichen Statistiken schaut, sie haben die wenigsten Torschüsse mit 185 in der 2. Bundesliga. Sie haben ihre Expected Goals deutlich überperformt, mit knapp vier, zumindest laut bundesliga.de Statistiken. Sie stehen jetzt nicht ganz zu Unrecht da unten, aber die 2. Liga sollte trotzdem gewarnt sein, weil Sathäus in den letzten Jahren immer gezeigt hat, dass man das irgendwie schafft, da wieder rauszukommen. Und jetzt auch die letzten Ergebnisse zeigen, dass sie sich mit Sicherheit da jetzt nicht unten aufgeben werden, sondern sie stehen ja genau für diesen Fußball. Die Mannschaft ist auch weitgehend dafür zusammengestellt, in diesen Tabellenregionen auch in harten Situationen, die vielleicht dann im März, April kommen, zu performen. Also abschreiben würde die Sathäus jetzt erstmal nicht, aber ich war überrascht, als ich jetzt nach dem Sonntagsspiel auf die Tabelle geschaut habe und sie standen da. Aber so vom Leistungsvermögen stehen sie da jetzt auch nicht ganz zu Unrecht, ganz hinten drin.
Es ist ja auch extrem gestaucht da hinten. Also das sieht so ein bisschen, die Tabelle ist quasi wie so ein bisschen so ein Auffahrunfall. Also hinten, da sind drei Punkte fehlen zu Platz 11. Also das ist eine Momentaufnahme. Aber dennoch geht man eben einfach als 18. in die Winterpause. Eva, ich weiß aus zuverlässiger Quelle, dass du fast so ein Überquest vor Informationen zum SV 2000. Keine Ahnung, wie das passieren konnte. Bitte teile sie mit uns.
Nein, ich habe ja – es ist immer schön zu wissen, wenn man ExpertInnen zu einem Verein befragt und sagt, ja erzähl mir mal noch mal ein bisschen was, dass man denkt, okay, 80 Prozent hätte ich jetzt auch noch gewusst von dem. Nein, aber ich hatte Louis Löser, der ja auch für den Hartwald Hörfunk – das ist jedes Mal zum Umbrecher dieses Wort – arbeitet. Und daher, ja, ich sage jetzt mal, die Ehre hat, 90 Minuten lang Sandhausen-Spiele regelmäßig zu sehen. Den habe ich einfach noch mal gefragt.
Und dann live darüber zu sprechen.
Das ist wirklich eine besondere Ehre. Da habe ich einfach mal gefragt, Luis, wie sieht es denn mit Sandhausen aus? Also ich meine, ist halt auch keine ungewohnte Lage, wo sie sich befinden am Ende einer Hinrunde. Aus den letzten vier Jahren standen sie dreimal unter den letzten drei am Ende der Hinrunde. Aber, also, hat Luis auch gesagt und sieht man natürlich auch, also was man ja eigentlich bei Alois Schwarz kennt, ist ja, okay, erst mal defensive Stabilität. Gut. Ist jetzt bei 29 Toren so mäßig gegeben? Also man hat eben nur vier Gegentore weniger als Magdeburg und eben in den letzten Ballspielen sehr, sehr viel kassiert in dem Sinne. Also wie gesagt, acht Gegentore in den letzten beiden Spielen vor eben 21 in 15. Das ist schon eher so. Ich glaube, das größte Problem einfach, was Sandhausen hat, ist, dass ein Stürmer vorne drin fehlt. Also ein Pull-Crab, der geholt wurde als Test-Rot-Ersatz, der ja gleich zur Ingolstadt in die dritte Liga gegangen ist, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Spielt halt überhaupt gar keine Rolle. Also zu Beginn schon vielleicht noch regelmäßiger gespielt, jetzt eigentlich kaum noch. Man spricht halt, wenn man über den Sturm spricht, vor allem über die beiden Kinzombie-Brüder, die da eben vor allem für die Tore verantwortlich sind. Und die kreieren David Kinzombie eben mit 6 Toren der beste Torschütze. Alexander Eswein spielt zwischenzeitlich Doppelspitze. Also ich sag mal so, das hatte ich jetzt nicht auf meinem Bingo-Zettel, so zu Beginn der Saison. Generell habe ich Alexander Eswein auch lange Zeit immer wieder bei Sandhausen verdrängt. Und wer auch ein sehr interessanter Spieler ist, der Tom Tribble ja tatsächlich auch so ein bisschen verdrängt hat, ist Papehler, ist ja von Mainz ausgeliehen. Das ist schon so einer der Lichtblicke, die Sandhausen hat. Aber sie haben auch irgendwie – Chirov hat glaube ich jetzt schon zwei Eigentore erzielt. Auch immer sehr unglücklich, möchte ich sagen. Und man sieht halt ganz, ganz stark, dass auch ein Chima Okurochi da einfach fehlt. Sandhausen hat gerade zum Ende letzter Saison durch Standards unfassbar viel Gefahr ausgestrahlt. Eben auch durch Okurochi, der hat ja auch glaube ich gegen Karlsruhe Ende letzter Saison diese direkte Ecke, die dann ins Tor ging, das fehlt einfach. Also man ist auf Platz 13 bei Eckballgefahr, Platz 15 Freistoßgefahr. Das war immer so das, dann hatte man irgendwie Bachmann oder Cirov als Brecher da irgendwie noch vorne stehen, die die Dinger gemacht hat, das fehlt einfach. Also die S-Wein schießt glaube ich hauptsächlich die Standards. Das ist halt ein Punkt, der Sandhausen immer noch so ein bisschen rausgeholt hat, auch in engeren Spielen. Und oftmals war ja so, das kennt man unter Schwarz, da will man halt zwei, drei Nadelstiche setzen im Spiel. Und dann kann man halt auch mal so ein Spiel wie gegen Hansa Rostock gewinnen, oder eben auch gegen Magdeburg. Ich glaube, das ist halt eben noch auch so der Punkt, warum man eben nicht komplett weg irgendwie vom Fenster ist. Aber ja, also ich glaube, dieser gute Saisonbeginn und halt eben die Siege gegen Magdeburg und Rostock sind die, die ja noch dazu führen, dass Sandhausen eben nicht abgeschlagen letzter ist. Gleichzeitig aber halt nochmal auch, es ist halt keine ungewohnte Situation von Sandhausen. Wir werden wahrscheinlich wieder 18 neue Transfers haben. Das hat man ja die letzten Saison schon gesehen. Da kann durchaus schon ordentlich Bewegung bei Sandhausen und jetzt reinkommen im Winterspiel. Ich will nicht ausschließen, aber ich glaube vor allem, dass wir zu Beginn der Rückrunde da auf der Stürmerposition neun Kandidaten sehen.
Also im letzten Winter waren es acht Spieler, die gekommen sind. Wenn ich das hier richtig sehe und dafür sind da nochmal sechs gegangen. Also der SVS ist da gerne mal aktiv. Und jetzt hat man ja auch sogar noch ein bisschen mehr Zeit in dieser Winterpause. Tim, welchen Eindruck hat auf dich Sandhausen hinterlassen?
Also ich mag das gar nicht sagen, aber Sandhausen ist auf jeden Fall das schwächste Team der Liga, wenn man sich Offensivstatistiken anschaut. In fast sämtlichen Passstatistiken sind sie total weit hinten, Pässe ins letzte Drittel, Pässe in den Strafraum, progressive Pässe, Schnittstellen-Pässe. Überall sieht man unten, ganz unten den SVS. Und das ist auch etwas, wenn man das mal vergleicht, was so die Anzahl an Pässen angeht in die Strafräume. Da sieht man auch, dass der erste FC Heidenheim nicht so viel mehr hat als Sandhausen. Aber da ist eben der Unterschied, dass sie ganz anders spielen, über Umschaltmomente sehr laufstark sind. Wenn man sich jetzt mal Heidenheim gegen den SV Sandhausen in der Laufstärke anschaut, dann sieht man eben, Heidenheim ist ganz vorne in Laufdistance, Anzahl Sprints, intensive Läufe. Und der SV Sandhausen ist ganz hinten in diesen Statistiken. Das ist, glaube ich, einer der großen Unterschiede, wenn man schon ein Team aufbaut, das defensiv über so eine gewisse Kompaktheit kommen muss, kommen will, dann muss die offensive Spielidee ja im Grunde diese Umschaltmomente sein. Und das hat Sandhausen eben nicht. Da ist gar nicht diese Gefahr vorhanden, die andere Teams dann entwickeln oder verfeinern, sei es Kaiserslautern, sei es Braunschweig, sei es Heidenheim, die ja sozusagen die Könige darin sind, oder sogar Darmstadt 98, die dann ganz oben sozusagen der Größe sind. Aber bei Sandhausen ist sozusagen die defensive Spielidee, diese Kompaktheit – wir reden hier über viele Gegentore – die funktioniert noch nicht mal richtig, muss man ja fast so sagen oder muss man so sagen. Und dann eben die offensive Spielidee, die noch viel weniger funktioniert. Und ja, das hängt mit Sicherheit zu großen Teilen auch am Personal, an Schwierigkeiten. Auf der anderen Seite muss man auch sagen, dass sie dann in Rostock, das Spiel in Rostock, dass sie das dann auch gewonnen haben. Und sich dann eben dann doch irgendwie auch, da haben sie sich tatsächlich auch an einer eigenen Ballbesitzidee festgehalten und das teilweise auch ganz gut umgesetzt. Und das sind dann gerade eben die Kinzombie-Brüder, die da eine entscheidende Rolle bei spielen. Aber ob die das wirklich durch die ganze Saison tragen können und wirklich dazu verhelfen können, ich weiß, Sandhausen wird jedes Jahr und meist in der Winterpause einfach schon mal komplett abgeschrieben. Vor der Saison sowieso immer dann in der Winterpause erst recht. Und dann ziehen sie irgendwie immer noch den Kopf aus der Schlinge. Und ich sage das dann dieses Jahr auch wieder. Wahrscheinlich werde ich Lügen gestraft. Aber ich glaube, dieses Jahr wird es wirklich eng für Sandhausen.
Wir werden es genau beobachten. Und ich werde genau hinhören. Singt man eigentlich die Cranberries immer, wenn die Kinzombie-Brüder ein Tor machen in den Fankurven in Sandhausen? Also das wäre doch super. Also würde ich machen. Na gut, egal. Also dann vielleicht reicht es jetzt auch. Vielleicht bin ich jetzt auch durch für diese Saison. Ich möchte es nicht komplett ausschließen. Ihr Lieben, ich kann mich nur bei euch bedanken. Wie war das nochmal? Haben wir nicht aufgrund der Länge uns dafür entschieden, weniger Teams zu besprechen und nicht alle Teams zu besprechen? Also ich hatte da aber auch irgendwie das Gefühl, dass ihr alle hier immer noch was Neues hinzuzufügen habt. Also ich hoffe, dass ihr jetzt nicht irgendwelche anderen Termine verschieben müsstet. Umso mehr danke ich euch für eure Zeit. Das wir jetzt so ausführlich auf die 2. Männer-Bundesliga geblickt haben. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an Eva-Lotta Bohle vom 2. Bundesliga-Pod. Da kann man dich natürlich auch hören und das kann ich auch sehr empfehlen. Auch für diejenigen, die sagen, Mensch, das ist auf Englisch, vielleicht verstehe ich das nicht. Doch, das tut ihr. Hört dazu. Es ist sehr gewinnbringend. Da kann man dann auch mal Michael Fischer auf Englisch sprechen hören. Das ist doch auch interessant. At Eva-Bohle auf Twitter. Danke dir, Eva, dass du mit dabei warst.
Vielen Dank, wie immer, für die Einladung auch, dass du die Selbst-Einladung von Michi und mir nicht einfach abgeschlagen hast.
Ich habe euch doch immer gerne hier. Das weißt du doch. Und gerade diese Kombination aus beiden, die ist ja euch beiden, die ist ja pures Podcastgold. Deswegen auch herzlichen Dank an Michi Fischer von Fürther Flachpass als at Flachpass unterstrich auch auf Twitter. Danke dir, Michi, dass du immer wieder hier warst. Du weißt, ich freue mich da immer sehr drüber.
Ich habe mich auch sehr gefreut über die, in Anführungszeichen, Einladung. Und nein, es ist keine Freude, mir auf Englisch zuzuhören. Das weiß Eva auch. Und nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Ich musste am Sonntag wieder mit Usama Hadadi auf Englisch sprechen. Es war keine Wohltat und das wird zum Glück nie aufgezeichnet. Ich musste es nur schriftlich verwerten. Das ist sehr gut, wenn ich Englisch spreche.
Naja, also ich sehe das ein bisschen anders. Aber danke dir, dass du hier warst. Und herzlichen Dank auch an Tim Ecksteen vom Millanturn, der ettim-exteen. Auch auf Twitter. Tim, schön, dass du hier warst. Das hat sich ja irgendwie mit Darmstadt nochmal so angeboten. Und Glückwunsch zu den gut formulierten Fragen. Das war wirklich eine beeindruckende Pressekonferenz. Es ist auch lustig, die YouTube-Kommentare dazu durchzulesen. Also herzlichen Dank, dass du hier im Rasenfunk mit dabei warst.
Ja, danke für die Einladung, Max.
Sehr, sehr gerne. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke ich für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war es jetzt erst mal, zumindest für einen kurzen Moment hier im Rasenfunk. Wir verabschieden uns in eine kurze Pause. Es wird nichts zur Männer-WM in Katar geben. Wer sich dafür interessiert, warum, wir dazu nicht berichten. Am Ende der letzten Schlusskonferenz, die auch erst am Dienstag, also heute erschienen ist – ne, gestern ist sie erschienen, ne? Gefühlt war es heute. Da habe ich dazu nochmal ein paar Worte verloren. Da könnt ihr euch das anhören. Hier im Rasenfunk geht es dann folgendermaßen weiter. Es gibt noch zwei Sendungen zur Frauen-Bundesliga, einen Kurzpass und eine Schlusskonferenz. Und eventuell wird auch noch ein Tribüngespräch erscheinen. Und ansonsten war es das mit diesem Rasenfunk. Ja, vielleicht machen wir auch noch so ein Q&A, Frank und ich. Aber das müssen wir mal schauen. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Unterstützung. Bitte registriert euch als Supporterinnen und Supporter. Rasenfunk.de slash Supporters Club. Und ansonsten habt eine gute Zeit. Achso, ja. Und das Hönesbuch kommt jetzt im Januar raus. Ich gehe auf Lesereise. Auf maxost.de erfahrt ihr, wohin ich da komme. Vielleicht können wir da ja auch Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen-Treffen draus machen. In diesem Sinne. Bleibt gesund. Habt eine gute Zeit. Wie auch immer ihr den Winter verbringt.
Ja, dann werden wir da ein paar Sachen ein bisschen neu justieren, aber so wie sie es jetzt schon gespielt haben, gibt es da gar nicht so viel, was man total umkrempeln muss. Da freue ich mich drauf. Schöne Weihnachten euch alle, dann jetzt schon. Schöne WM, ja, Schwachsinns-WM.